we never got to taste the dinosaur like
a t-rex probably tasted great
t-rex would be gamey as [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding me velociraptor is like
good size no too muscular they're right
that would be too tough what's the
[ __ ] long neck shits that's uh
gamer's game is game i remember whenever
that like message came up in the cinemas
it like always just scared me
message that you wouldn't steal a car
why did that cinemas why did that become
like the standard why did everyone use
that one what they wouldn't steal a car
yeah that one why did that become the
one because that's the argument that
because it was the easiest to like
explain it yeah but like why did
everyone just take that exact video clip
and use it in everything like
because
did you were you grow did you grow up in
the blockbuster era or like that yeah
i've i've got games mainly from
blockbuster okay so basically why that
became a meme is because at the start of
every movie that you rent from like
blockbuster or anything that one message
would show up yeah i know that yeah but
then like what
it was also in like non-blockbuster
things like why did that video that
thing get just used everywhere why did
everyone agree this was it was the
videos i don't know it was something
because for me it played before every
movie yeah yeah every movie ever had it
yeah oh i didn't see it in movies yeah i
only know it from the cinemas oh i only
know from like rental stuff really
welcome this episode of trash taste
that's a strange topic that we didn't
mean to get on but uh welcome i'm your
host connor with the boys cheering on
although as we've established the host
means nothing now as someone on the
trash case reddit uh pointed out i
explained to them i was like on my live
stream i was like listen you don't
understand you get power when you're on
the solo scene you get space you do yeah
i i don't know how to explain it you
just get like a feeling that you you're
like i mean i'm in control i'm in the
conversation like like every time when i
hosted before and there was a guest
story i'm just like well that's that's
my hosting privilege it's gone because i
got to take care of the guests i'm on
babysitter mode now now you're in the
beta seat i hate that suit the most i
feel like i'm furthest away from
everything i'm like hi guys
i'm crushed yellow crust
a part of me just feels like i like
these two seats i like that scene i like
this sheet too
that's literally never giving a [ __ ]
something about it just you know feels
different you know it's
it's like
it's like getting like the front seat in
the car you know you you are you are the
alpha male if you're five years old yes
you are
oh okay i'm sorry every time we go on a
road trip joey's the one that shotguns
the front seat every [ __ ] time i
swear to god
yeah exactly i'm doing i'm doing it for
the driver all right there's more
responsibility for me you can chill in
the back see the front seat's only good
if the driver is also really confident
because the driver is confident that
he's not going to bother you yeah with
the driver but if the driver is not
confident then he's going to bug you
okay can you look at the map actually
can you change the song
we can stop there's like no but if the
drivers are chatting but even if it's a
confident driver right you're going to
be the one guy who's like you know
someone in the back is going to be like
can you turn up the ac it's like oh fine
[ __ ] all right that's awesome this is
why i feel sorry for any short person
who is on a group road trip right
because here's the thing isn't it
no matter what no matter what we think
no matter what we think is the best c in
the car we can all unanimously agree
that the worst c is the middle c in the
back right yeah and who always gets that
it's the short person because they take
up the least space because i can always
be like look guys i'm a bit tall can i
can i can i get at least can i at least
get one of the side seats and everyone's
like all right guys i understand i'm
just like i love i love how the people
throw in that argument as if like the
the ones on the one that is in the
middle seat has more legroom or
something like we all have the same
amount of leg room so it's like you're
you're like worrying about invading two
people's leg room yeah as opposed to
just guarding your oh is that the lawyer
i think so but also it doesn't really
have to do that much with heights yeah
it's about which yeah yeah like because
you could be like eric cartman right
eric cartman is like
everyone in south park yeah like like
how where where is he gonna sit yeah you
know i mean yeah for me it's always like
it's it's whoever has like the smallest
stature
which a lot of the times happens to be
the shortest person oh that's true but
there are some like short thick people
out there in the wall so i was like
i'm sure they are but i'm just saying
every time every time because i'm i'm
always the person that forgets like
shotgun the front seat so i'm just like
if i can't get the front seat there's
i'm there's no way in hell i'm getting
the middle seat you'll catch her dead
oh you want you want me to take the
middle c oh okay well uh oh i guess
these long legs have no space to sit hey
oh let me just let me just uh i'm just
man
as much let me just like man spread as
much as possible so you can regret this
decision of putting me in the middle
seat god's polite enough their way if
you're like god get in the middle seat
don't be like all right yeah yeah
but it depends on the length of the
journey if it's a short journey i'm like
i'll i'll take the middle i don't know
really yeah even even in a short trip i
don't want the middle like an hour in
the middle i can do an hour and a minute
that was short
yeah
i'd say like four hours where it gets
like long four hours you can throw me in
the trunk man
i'll have a better time in there
yeah i don't know like it's it's the
middle c especially it's not just like
the least comfortable it's just the one
that induces the most motion sickness
for me as well because i don't get
motion sick the problem with the middle
seat is that it's always got like the
shittiest seat belt right like like
the waist
yeah it's the waste only one so it feels
like the the top half just like has less
um what's the word i'm looking for like
supports it has less support right
you're you're nice and snug makes you
motion sick yeah it kind of like
a lot of things make me worse one of
those people who literally needs to be
like [ __ ] straight jacketed into the
seat to be like no motion sickness for
me because because the other thing as
well is a lot of the times the middle c
doesn't have a head rest as well so a
lot of part of part of the thing that
helps me with motion sickness is having
something to rest my head on it sounds
like a tall person problem it it very
much is a tall person pop problem either
i get motion sickness or i just have
like massive whiplash from just like
trying to lie
trying to lie like this for like two
hours well then after saying all of that
can you really fault me for shotgun in
the front seat
clearly so i can avoid [ __ ] sitting
like this for the entire trip right no
that's why uh that's why that's why
short people deserve to be in the middle
[Laughter]
it is
as it is i i need a head rest okay
can't hate short people confirmed
he wants them all to sit in the middle
seat for the rest of time this is the
birth of heightism
is that a thing is that a thing
maybe probably
if you're on tinder you can't
you can't call them short
that's that's going to end up being
derogatory at one point of our lives
because everything ends up being
derogatory also there's no clear
definition for when somebody becomes
sure exactly right vertically challenged
that's all we have to start using from
now on
yeah at which point what what is the
cut-off for like shorts well it depends
how tall you are how self-conscious you
are it depends on where you are as well
some guys say anything below six foot
you're a dwarf yeah
but then again it's like who says that
i say that insecure men
it depends well i think the definition
of short is dependent on like your point
of reference right also the country that
you're in right yes if you're from
netherlands then everyone here is short
yeah i feel like an average size human
being in the uk and then i move to like
thailand and like the toilets come up to
my shins that's that's like the biggest
like indicator of when i go to like
thailand i can't remember i i think
japan is like kind of the same where i
go in the public toilets and normally
like it goes up to like my knees yeah
but then the toilets there go up to my
shins and i'm just like what is this
what is this country yeah but like
there's some japanese high school kids
that are [ __ ] massive yeah yeah
something i've noticed walk on the train
they'll be like six foot five and i'm
like oh my god i've kind of noticed that
they're like i feel
that when i first moved here or even
earlier than that everyone around me was
shorter than me but nowadays like as you
said there are like seven feet tall high
school kids and it's like what happened
the entire country just had like a
growth
because because i remember i remember
that was anecdotal yeah it's totally
anecdotal but like i remember at one
point when i was in high school because
i basically i reckon i stopped growing
around like 16 17. i'm still growing
copium
are you no no i'm not
i i personally stopped going in around
like 16 17. right so right before i
graduated high school and i remember
there was one time where i was on an
absolutely packed train in tokyo and i i
i was like a [ __ ] q-tip in a field of
like cotton swabs like i was just it was
just me and then it's just like a sea of
heads but nowadays i'm just like i get
in a packed train and i'm like everyone
around me is the same height as me like
what happened
why am i baiting is everyone like
i thought i was the only one who
thought he was built different it's
about the exact same as everyone else i
was like i'm exclusively in the six foot
club now everyone is in the six foot
club
well
aside from coming so actually that's
aside from connor as is evident in like
every photo we take it's surprising that
we've taken this many photos and we
still get the same
we get we still get the same three
comments every [ __ ] time asians are
taller than white people no which is i
don't know i didn't expect connor to be
the shortest which con mcconnell is not
a short guy she called us not short
that's the thing you're not a short dude
no you're not sure incredible meme right
now you guys are like happy i'm like the
[ __ ] pain yeah
i'm not sure
but yeah but the thing is you're ten but
i think you're not short
i don't really
especially in this country
i don't feel i don't feel short no yeah
but like you meet people you're like i
am i am tiny on this earth well yeah i
mean every time i go to the netherlands
i'm like oh i am literally vertically
challenged right now yeah compared to
everyone else but in japan it's like you
know you meet people who are like three
feet tall and they're living their lives
normally so i'm like good good on you i
guess
you're like why are you living
is it tough is it time
why are you why are you doing this
why give up
my girlfriend is literally the shortest
person i know so yeah i don't know i
don't give a [ __ ] about height i don't
know i think i think it's one of those
things that people really care about and
when they do i'm like why i've been
people who are like i will only date
someone unless they're like that's the
common thing right right i'm like why
why though
like what are the privileges of being
taller than a certain positive
preference right you might like really i
know guys who love taller women than
them they love women that are told them
i get that nothing against that but like
i guess it's the wording right yeah some
girls just
when they when they're worded i i can
understand why it hurts some of those
guys out there that are like i just
wanted a break man
and then i just not six foot and i'm
like it's all right man it's all right
don't worry about it don't worry i don't
get it like why is it just that cut off
you know it's just i don't know it's
it's it's always weird to me i'm yet to
meet a woman who was like man i want a
man who's at least four feet tall just
every man be like
thank you
thank you inclusive
i don't know why i think six foot sounds
nice
what about like 175 centimeters or
something
180 centimeters that's
i don't know it's around the same right
what's what's six foot again 180 i think
180 100
something like that i don't know i'm
exactly six foot so whatever i am that's
not a new standard in metric joey's like
just made it yeah i literally i was like
just scraped by there was a god i grew
two millimeters last year and i just
scraped by what uh
i'm not even six foot
i always thought i always thought six
foot was 180.
joey your car you're kind of looking up
you got it looking mighty short right
now joe you're kind of looking mighty
sure right now it's technically 182.8
yeah okay hold on i know what i am in
centimeters let me let me off that's
okay it'll make your dick look bigger
hey hey siri
hey sir [ __ ] siri wake up hey siri
what's
181.2 centimeters
how desperate shut up i'm desperate shut
up
she picked up all that
the answer is 100 over 381
that's fine
hey siri
what's 181 centimeters in feet in inches
is 5.94 feet
5.94 which that's what 511
right it's it's not five foot nine
inches it's five point nine four feet
which is five uh which means it's five
eleven how many feet how many inches
but it's nice but it's not uh it's not
six but it's not six though that's all
that matters that's the important part
it's not six which means you must be six
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's the chat how
does it feel
if you're a real chad jerry i just can't
ask a real chat
i thought i thought you were a brother
to me i thought i was gay
i like my height it's a comfortable high
i see like people taller than me and
like i'm at the height where there are
some things especially in japan where it
just gets a bit inconvenient right but
like i like some some some buildings are
like i need to like you know just bob my
head down a little bit i can't imagine
what it's like for someone who's like
six five or something yeah like trying
to live in japan could you imagine
having a duck down every time you go
into a trailer remember that toilet we
went into in that one bar
we found this toilet in this bar and i
posted a video to twitter but like it
was like a closet it was like this tiny
little door opened and you had to no
joke like duck down to like maybe four
foot yeah it was like the it was like
[ __ ] harry's room in [ __ ]
philosophy yeah
it was crazy it said toilet on the wall
and i thought
the [ __ ] it looks like some kind of like
like some kind of old 1800s charcoal
storage room yeah yeah it was like it
was it was literally like out of snow
white and i said that seven dwarfs you
know it was that was just like
[ __ ] i don't understand because the room
wasn't that small the room was quite big
yeah it wasn't but the door was
comically small but i liked that that
was wow you feel like a hobbit i don't
know it just it just looked cool well i
guess it looks unusual we're talking
about it now it was it was like the bar
at uh in nissiko remember the one where
where it was like the the fridge door to
get in and yeah everyone had to duck
down together
that was cool that was cool there's
something about like having a crawl to
just take a [ __ ] this is like shawshank
redemption-esque
and then i could get in i thought that
was just like really small i don't know
i thought it was like is there no
regulations around door sizes in japan
no apparently not i'm sure in the uk we
have some like kind of rule that's like
why would there be why would that be
just for like you know because and maybe
get to the point where you're like all
right to get to the toilet you have to
climb through the vent by the way this
is a mission impossible themed cafe and
it's like ah well it depends what do you
constitute as a door yeah exactly
what is it like a cover what is the door
i felt like it was they were like
stretching the definition of a door yeah
the same way like you know if i were to
uh
it's a fridge door it was about the same
height as a fridge store yeah yeah i
would say so as well it was not like a
small fridge it was just impressive i
was like okay
why not just like knock a bit of the
wall down and make a bigger door like
does it i could get what they're going
for they're just going for like a unique
i don't think it would go in the box to
be fair the bar itself was pretty small
would you describe it like a diner
yeah like like a diner kind of there was
one there was one bar top and then there
was like two or three maybe like two
like three seater like bar tops but it
looked like the classic diner seats oh
yeah yeah like the black and white
there's just like some random bar
because we were finding a place that was
open yeah yeah i don't know why the
toilet fit into the theme there was
nothing to indicate that i would
it was like a hobbit theme or anything
okay
it was really strange but you find us in
japan occasionally just random places
with like the weirdest toilets or doors
yeah there's an izakaya in shibuya that
i go to a few times where the entrance
to it is basically the toilet door yeah
where it's maybe up to like here for me
oh my god yeah on this on the street
mind you on the main street what yeah so
people who walk in you just see people
[ __ ] doing get in on the main road
it's so weird yeah you do see some
strange toilets in japan i remember like
it's sometimes it's just a strange
layout because i remember that one
toilet uh i think you also tweeted this
one out as well which is i think we were
like having dinner with people from
netflix or something and there was this
toilet in there that was just in the
corner and the lighting was like so
ominous that it felt like you were
approaching a jojo stand yeah you know
it was like it was like it was like
diagonal yeah it was like diagonal in
this room it was just just leading to
this one toilet and all the lighting was
just behind this one that hit this one
toilet seat yeah
like the toilet of the promised land
it's like
japan has that because i feel like the
restaurant comes first then whatever the
[ __ ] they can fit the toilet and they do
it i mean not that we can really talk we
have a [ __ ] toilet over there that's
in the corner it's weird as well it's a
weird toilet yeah yeah
but i know that there's like um
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
when you use the bathroom you always
close the door behind you right well not
having expressvpn is like going to the
toilet but the door is wide open
everyone can see you doing your business
and you don't want people staring in at
your business because did you know that
your internet service provider knows
every single website you visit and
what's worse is that they can sell this
information add companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you but luckily expressvpn is here to
put a stop to that it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity can't be seen by anyone i
personally use the expressvpn on all my
devices obviously i use it on my pc
right here but i also use it on my phone
on my ipad even on my router and the
best part is using expressvpn is as easy
as closing the bathroom door you just
fire up the app click one button and
boom you're protected plus expressvpn is
the world's number one rated vpn by
mashable the verge and countless others
so if you're like me and you believe
that your online activity is your own
business secure yourself by going over
to expressvpn.com trash taste today use
our link expressvpn.com
taste and you can get an extra three
months free that's expressvpn.com trash
taste links in the description below
thank you sweet vpn for sponsoring this
episode back to the show how do you guys
feel about just the different like
themes of like the restaurants you find
here because i feel like in japan
there are more like you there
you there are more ways that you can
find just like really uniquely done like
little cafes or restaurants more than
i've seen in like basically where where
i came from or even london to me i think
more so bars there's more themed bars
yeah yeah yeah exactly like a lot of
bars bars and cafes mostly yeah yeah you
look at some of these bars and you think
how the [ __ ] do you stay in business
right because some of these bars are
tiny it's like you think of a bar at
least in like the uk and america and you
think it's a it's a building you know
it's it's it's a it's a building with a
dedicated room with tables and chairs
and that is the bar and some of these
bars are just a countertop you're
talking about the one we found the other
night yeah yeah yeah yeah the one that
was literally the size of a hallway yeah
that was so weird guys yeah building you
want to tell the story yeah so we
basically it was after the the really
short toilet bar right and we were like
oh we're feeling good so you know it's
been a while since the three of us had
like gone out to go drink and stuff like
that so we were like let's let's go to
this other place in tokyo called
uh which has like a lot of like small
hidden bars and clubs and stuff like
that all over the place and by hidden we
mean like there's one road that is just
like
covered there's like buildings that have
like you know maybe 20 30 bars in it
yeah over like six stories or something
yeah yeah they were like maybe some like
six to ten story buildings and they just
had like
the signs were from the top to the
bottom
and it's just like 30 40.
so we just like let's just go into one
of them and the one we went into
was like really like pristine and like
very like shiny and very like chic which
is weird because outside of it it looks
like a normal apartment building yeah
yeah and like really grinding you get
off you get off the elevator i think it
was on like the fourth or fifth floor
you get off the elevator and it's just
this dark hallway yellowish building
color yeah the doors of this horrible
any other country
any other country that is like a floor
where you would get stabbed yeah exactly
but yeah there was like three or four
bars that were open this was like let's
just go into one of them we went in
really pristine like silver chic looking
thing and there was this like
old lady at the end yeah
uh that was like you know drinking
something really expensive but yeah the
size of this place was maybe what four
people could sit at the bar yeah i mean
i think about six because i remember
there was lady on one end and we were on
the other end and they were like two
seats between us and the lady yeah and
that's all it could see
and that's it and the width was
literally the size of a hallway yeah
yeah exactly
exactly and they had three people
running this bar for a bar that can seat
six people just as many bar men behind
the bar as there were people sitting at
the bar exactly it was really awkward we
walked in there and it was like this
woman
quite elderly woman in like a kimono
yeah drinking like don perrion clearly
like a really important yeah
these like three bartenders were like
all caring for like laughing at
everything she was saying yeah and then
we walked in and they kind of went like
what do you guys want
and we said we're like
they were like
fine and they gave us like a bog
standard uh beer from a a glass that
cost us 20
yeah to be fair though we did eat like
all of their complimentary snacks yeah
hey they brought out a lot of stuff i
don't know what the [ __ ] snack that was
but it was so good whatever it was like
these were like your average bar snacks
they were like like premium stuff like
dried fruits and stuff yeah and every
time we ate them they immediately
refilled it and i started feeling really
bad because like we must have it like i
saw them like opening new packs
like reluctantly pouring more snacks for
us
but it was just like the atmosphere was
like really weird it was a bit weird
yeah it was like because then when the
elderly woman left like two of the
bartenders followed her out and just
didn't come back
they might not have even worked at the
bar they might have just been like her
personal attendance yeah
there's like two there's two of them
like one of them was in like a tuxedo
yeah he was quite elderly as well yeah
and he looked like like the [ __ ]
butler from overlord
[Laughter]
uh
another guy yeah they were left and then
we were like they'll come back and they
never never came in but they all left at
one point they left us in the bar yeah
he was like alone for like five minutes
and we were like
this is only in japan would they leave
the bar with the customers still in
there just to make sure this like rich
customer can go and do yeah yeah yeah so
strange so strange it was very weird
yeah but like do you how do you think
some of these bars do stay in business
if if they do rich customers that are
regulars i know there's a big like
regular cut like uh what's the word
regular um
culture yeah yeah i think it's very
common to find a bar you like and just
only go to yeah yeah yeah i i like to
just constantly bar hop and just see
what else yeah yeah me too because like
some of these bars that you know you
kind of like discover like this one but
this is like one of like basically every
time we go out and discover a new place
we go into one of these kinds of bar
where it's like every time we go in the
bar is like almost empty or there's just
like that one person sitting uh sitting
in the corner like i remember when we
went out with jan as well yeah it was
just like the three of us and one person
in the corner and it's just this one
bartender who i saw it's just like
he's just chill he's just enjoying his
job which is just a delight to see and
you know i get it that's why like it's
it's so weird to me that tipping culture
isn't a thing and yet bars like this are
are able to stay in business because i
can't imagine bars like this thing in
business if there wasn't a tipping
culture right yeah because the drinks
were expensive but they weren't like
ridiculously expensive to the point
where one or two people can in my mind
at least run the entire
run the entire bar economy and keep it
afloat so it just it just blows my mind
that's really nice yeah i have i have a
maid actually who owns a bar in saitama
um yeah and uh like because uh my my
hairdresser at the time was like friends
with him so i got to know him through
that and he was just like oh and i was
just like curious because i was like how
many customers do you get because it's
kind of like inside time first of all
which is like far away from you right so
there's less of a population to you know
for customers but i'm like it was also
in like a really like hidden area right
like kind of similar to the one we went
to and i was like how many customers at
night do you get and he was like oh like
three or four on average oh my god and i
was like are you like how long are you
open for and he's like oh like two days
a week i'm like and this is your only
job and he's like yeah all the other
days that i'm off i would go skiing oh
and i was like how
how just
like where does this money come from and
he literally just said like i get three
to four customers but it's usually the
same three or four customers that just
keep coming back and are there literally
from bar open to bar close right just
because like they're his mates and this
is like the only time they get to hang
out with him while he's working kind of
thing right so kind of cool with sad at
the same time
yeah i mean he's enjoying it and you
know it's still around and everything
but it's just like really fascinating
how you can just
make that as a living yeah it goes into
like the other aspect of japanese
culture that is very prevalent where
they they like predictability they like
the same thing yeah yeah they want to
know what's going to happen i guess for
bot owner and customer it's good right
because yeah you get to go to the same
bar every day you get to know what
you're going to get and then if you're
the owner it's like great i know my
customers i know they're going to come
and yes xxx yeah because i i do think
that like that's the really cool
part of bar culture in japan is that you
like there are so many small little
places and there's like places that you
would never be able to do in any other
country or at least in any other country
that i've lived in
um because that kind of like that kind
of business model just wouldn't work
yeah you know you have to have that
dedication of your regular customers and
even
there has to be like it's like kind of
like a symbiotic relationship right that
the customers always need to be there
and the customers come back knowing that
they are the ones that are keeping this
bar in business and they are the only
ones but i guess what i wanted to know
is like how do you establish yourself
with that
how much how did you how did you like i
just i think it's literally just word of
mouth at that point the tournament was
so fast yeah like i know that
restaurants and and bars close and open
very fast in japan so i imagine that a
lot of them unfortunately fail yeah i
know like ramen stores are like
incredibly expensive to start and
operate oh it's also incredibly
competitive yeah yeah exactly you can
get ramen at any street corner yeah and
then you just get destroyed by by uh
yeah you either get destroyed by each
one or like a mcdonald's yeah yeah like
one of the mega corporations well it's
like yeah i don't know it's i literally
think it's just like a mate like you
know if one of your mates is like i'm
going to start a bar in x location yeah
you'll be like oh i'll come and check it
out one night and then you go tell your
mates about it and then yeah that
friendship forms and then that symbiotic
relationship forms and then
if it keeps going well
it'll keep growing out but i mean with
how quick it you know with a bar is
there much expenses to start out with
apart from obviously getting the
location i guess all the alcohol
is quite expensive you need to like i
mean the bars the bars we went to some
of them were in like an apartment
building so they were based they were
basically just someone's someone's
apartment right but the way they
renovated this bar it looks [ __ ]
great you know there was so many small
touches in every bar we go to so i'm
sure a lot of it was also spent on
renovation just to make it look like a
bar
yeah yeah yeah i think we went to two
bars that night i remember the second
one was a lot more themed but the first
one was very chill very nice yeah and i
think i think they were reasonably
priced because this guy would spend like
10 minutes making a drink yeah yeah like
could he have been faster yeah probably
but but it was nice watching it's like i
feel like that's part of the experience
in these like cool bars like you just
get to watch the guy just go ham yeah do
little things just make something cool
and then i taste it and i don't really
taste much difference in other drinks
but that's not the point is that it
feels nice it's the experience it's the
experience that you've it's like yeah
he's making your food yeah yeah yeah i
don't know it's really nice it's like
drinking weather spoons has like trained
my mind into being like i need to get
this drink as fast as possible
you mean you're like i order like mojito
and they'd better just be serving it in
a [ __ ] jug because otherwise this
time i'm waiting to get this mojito it
could be used to like drink something
else you know so just
going into these bars which are more
chilled out it's such a like different
but nice experience because you'd only
normally go to these bars in the uk if
you had like a [ __ ] ton of money to
spend i also feel you don't spend on
drinking so i personally don't go into
those bars to get shit-faced no no you
can't really yeah i mean you can if
you're there for long enough right
you're ordering stuff that's like easy
but it's at the same time it's like
you know if you're gonna pay for that
experience and that like atmosphere
actual atmosphere then just like go easy
on your drinks right just go slowly it's
kind of hard because the atmosphere
doesn't really make you feel like you're
like drink drink yeah just take your
time take your time just relax let's
just talk about really let's just talk
also really thankful that i speak enough
japanese to be able to do those bars
like no pressure yeah because those bars
don't require that much yeah so i feel
like if you if there's any reason to
learn japanese probably just learn super
basic stuff so you can go to those bars
because if you don't speak any japanese
they might be like also it's a really
it's it's also a really good place to
practice japanese
um because i every time i go bar hopping
i you know but i get to speak more
japanese than i would normally and the
bar the bartenders are normally well
it's kind of their job to be way more
understanding and very and come it's
their job to interact with the customers
basically yeah exactly if you're going
to talk to the bartender they're not
going to be like
they might they might they pretty much
they're really nice i've never had i've
never been to one of those bars where
the bartender's been like rude right no
no they're always super nice yeah always
interesting well they wouldn't be in
business if they weren't that's true at
the end of the day it's customer service
there's only like six seats they better
be nice to every [ __ ] customer that
comes in yeah they can't be they can't
pretend to like oh what was that you
were saying like go go to a different
customer but you're not the only one
there
i've had other customers be rude while
i've been in those bars really all right
and they've been like i think one time i
was with chris and we were asking about
um it was also a bar that made food and
we were ordering a bunch of food because
we hadn't eaten all day because we were
like traveling and filming yeah and this
one woman was like don't you think
you've ordered enough food to like me
and chris and we're like never never
enough food
shut up you're like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you why would you say that to
someone [ __ ] off
i think it's the she was annoyed because
she was talking with him i think she was
like flirting with her and we kept
obviously making him like actually like
cook and yeah do his job i guess and she
was like really annoyed
like i see every time we ordered
anything she was like
and i'm like what's your problem
oh my god leave us alone we drank so
much
she's she's trying to get the d dude i
know she [ __ ] off let us eat it's
because we got a cameo there bro they
should have
been cheese and stuff you know christmas
is like more camembert
because we were drinking so much we were
getting hungry more
more more
imagine trying to give them business
i thought i was so rude i was like what
the [ __ ] wrong with you
i was in uh kochi i think as well isn't
this really tiny like well it's just
i i bet for her that's like the only
like you know maybe yeah solace out of
whatever she's living through right yeah
i don't know
clearly she wasn't very happy you should
want to take it out on
i mean it's caught you there isn't a
whole lot else yeah yeah
there's not much going on yeah [ __ ] you
i don't know it was a nice bar though i
remember it was like a it was like an
irish bar or something that's the theme
of it right right yeah it was really
good though because they did like they
had heineken on tap oh [ __ ] and i just
drank like and it was they had actual
pints of heineken oh yeah i was like
this is amazing way too much because i
was like so excited to finally have a
real sized pint yeah yeah oh my god it's
good though
amazing sorry random tangent random
times fine you guys haven't been to any
other like weirdly themed bars i mean i
know you have for a bunch for your
videos and stuff yeah like just outside
i don't know
a lot of the cool bars i wouldn't want
to go film anyway i'd probably just kind
of do it like there's that bar we went
to it's like this bar that's like i
don't i don't say it except i don't want
it to become like ramped yeah but it's
like they have like live music there and
that's oh really it was like dude
playing piano cello i don't know violin
and double bass
yeah like a jazz bar there's like and
it's there's like the whole wall there's
just like wine
yeah yeah yeah i remember that one
really cool and they have like cigars
and like the atmosphere's really chill
nice
yeah it's super awesome these dudes are
amazing they're super chill just being
there yeah i really miss going to a bar
that has live music because like it's
like good as well yeah okay because
sometimes you get live music you're like
i mean it's like not not too like
when the music's like not too in your
face yeah it wasn't too loud yeah yeah
sometimes you go to a bar and the music
the music like music is way too
aggressive that you can't focus on
anything else but the music yeah yeah
like this bar was just perfect the music
was just like you can have a
conversation or you can just like admire
this guy like
like tearing it up on like the trumpet
or saxophone right whenever he was
playing with the with the piano yeah
they were [ __ ] insane really cool you
can actually tip them aside
they're like a tip jar
yeah i assume that's how they make their
money there but it's really cool yeah
awesome but you get charged for just
like sitting down for like the music
charge oh yeah yeah yeah but they're
playing for like three hours yeah i mean
if the music's good
yeah it's really [ __ ] good yeah so
cool i used to go to so many of those
places in uh in australia but um like
they all just got [ __ ] replaced by
like just standard like
poker machines and like [ __ ]
what's the australian bar culture like
um i'd say pretty similar to the uk in
the sense that you go in you have you
know some food and you know beers and
whatnot and then you watch the footy on
the tv kind of deal you know because
because like to me like
would you count a pub as a bar
yeah yeah okay yeah it's not the same
but it is in definition it's it's it's i
guess it's the og it fulfills the scene
it's only since i've moved out of
england that i've considered a pub a bar
right because before like i mean i mean
i get it it's it's a place that you go
to drink but to me like a pub always
felt different in the uk at least to a
bar you know a pub somewhere where
most of the time you go there to drink
but you know you can just have like a
nice sunday lunch you can have like a
nice breakfast there or whatever as well
a bar is was always like somewhere you
would go before going to a club or
somewhere where you were 100 of the time
like spend the night getting [ __ ] faced
yeah yeah yeah yeah probably you can go
to like in the daytime as well i could
never like imagine having gone to a bar
before 5 p.m you know right right or
yeah i guess in that sense then a pub is
more so similar to an izakaya in japan
in that instance whereas like a bar is
just like uh like as you know live
drinking
most people normally go to at least in
the uk
see because for us it's like everyone
eats at the park honestly 70 people
don't eat when they go to the pub really
yeah young i think the older you get the
more likely you are to eat at the pub
i think it's just a thing because you
wanna because the older you get the more
you wanna on weekends you wanna go hang
out with your mates
yeah down for a sunday
yeah yeah maybe i don't know i like pubs
pubs are interesting in the uk because
it's one place where you know it's also
a [ __ ] but also it's where like
there's also
a [ __ ] ton of historical significance to
some of these pubs yeah some pubs have
been around like 800 years in the uk
isn't it insane yeah that's insane just
some guy just pouring drinks he's been
in there for like 800 years yeah it's
like four times the length of australia
isn't that isn't that insane like there
are like pubs that are still open that
have been around for like like 500 plus
years that's crazy maybe not the same
name but like the location is this is
insane yeah and you go in and it's
depressing
because of course it's been around for
like 500 years right
not much has changed i don't know pubs
are one of those places where it very
much reflects the local area
the state of it right like this is
the absolute state
you're going to the pub and you're like
all right we're we're going on if the
community is doing well the pub will be
nice
it's true everyone's happy the pub is
nice yeah that's true if it's an area
that has been like uh you know has been
like kind of forgotten by the the
shankings every week
you know it's kind of it's a it's a
reflection i don't know the pubs
it's like when you get to see the actual
i'd say the culture of the actual place
all right really it's probably the most
honest way to find out about it
i i i'd agree yeah i mean it's like if
you want to see what proper british
people are like you go departments you
go to pubs right yeah like
you'll see you'll see that there's a
difference well i mean i remember before
where the image was different but now
you know if you it's it's not all just
like either
how can i wear this it's not all either
like primo premium proper people or just
whatever the [ __ ] we're getting clowned
on on the internet now i remember when
when i went to the uk and you took me to
that
gaming pub
i don't know
me we both took you i mean yeah
no i'm pretty sure it was connor's idea
to bring you to that gaming con is like
i know what place
i think it was supposed to be chill but
i think that day specifically it was
because the overwatch
world fight world finals
happening really [ __ ] because it's just
so busy and you can't get on but even
even before the actual final started we
we got there a little bit early before
the finals actually started so we could
like at least get a few drinks in and
chill and everything and i was like in
my head you know i was like oh okay a
gaming pub in the uk all right i wonder
i wonder what they have they just had a
wii on the windowsill
a single wii with with smash that's it
and five five
pcs but the pieces were all taking up
because of the overwatch uh yeah yeah
yeah and uh i'd never been unironically
oid before until that night
when i was like sitting outside because
the overwatch finals were happening
inside it was like way too loud and i
didn't really care so i sat outside yeah
just because there were a couple of
seats outside yeah and yeah this this
dude clearly like about six pints in
just literally came up sat next to me it
was like oh yo
yeah that's all it is yeah that
i think i was playing in an overwatch
tournament that day i think was that
that day yeah i was like that was it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you are you you took
i think you i think you signed up yeah
yeah
it was like a the winner got a free
drink yeah
it was like it was like a six round
tournament yeah i got i think i won the
first four matches yeah but then i'm the
fifth match i was like six beers deep
yeah and so it was starting to get a lot
harder to win these 1v1s in overwatch
and then the guy i remember i got so
annoyed i was like the guy i'm going
against he was just drinking coffee and
i was like how is this fair i'm six
drinks deep and this guy he's just
drinking a [ __ ] starbucks yeah of
course i'm gonna lose i can barely like
[ __ ] sit in the chair correctly
and i didn't get my free drink i lost i
was very salty i think he was like a
[ __ ] rank as well i could have easily
been yeah it could have been
sorry that's not right yeah i i i do
notice that about it's especially like
themed bars in the uk because like the
uk the uk like themed bar game is
[ __ ] weak as [ __ ] i i don't know if
it's changed ever since i moved but like
you know like you you have in my day you
have a gaming bar in the uk right and
the gaming bar in the uk as joey has
just said it's just like a wii in a
corner and four pcs and the and the
stickiest wiimotes i've ever touched in
my life i was like
is it shut down now
it might be i don't know i don't know i
can't remember i can't remember real
quick
yeah yeah let me make sure they're not
in business before i
what was it called again i i can't
remember what it was called melt oh
meltdown that was it meltdown i think
that was shut down it's closed i think
it's closed and it keeps reopening and
closing
it's quite gritty though yeah yeah
all right i mean i still had a good time
it was better than nothing yeah
it was better than nothing but you
compare it to some of the gaming bars
and some of the theme bars you find some
of the gaming bars in tokyo are like
yeah in the uk they do have a new one
now i remember
i went there it's called called down no
it's called it's called uh i think right
now it's called platform
i think but it was very expensive like
to go on the pc it was like oh god um it
was like paying normal computer costs
like computer cafe costs in london yeah
like five pounds for an hour maybe right
or maybe 30 minutes it might have been
five pounds for 30 minutes yeah like
seven bucks and you weren't allowed to
take your drink up obviously but that
just kind of sucks let's see but like
that sounds like a gaming bar where the
gaming takes priority over the bar
right whereas whereas meltdown was
definitely like
ninety-two percent bar eight percent
gaming well
the thing i liked about meltdown was
that it was just i i don't know it's
just like it was just kind of like comfy
you know
you can you could do you could do
anything in that bar you could like
order food from like the local pizza
place and eat to that bar yeah yeah like
it was a cool place to chill out but in
terms of just like having like a cool
themed bar where like you know a lot of
effort has gone into like the theming
and the vibe i mean i've been to bars in
america i've been to bars in like you
know in japan and you know you for
example you have like an anime themed
bar you have like a jojo themed bar in
japan and pete and like you can tell you
walk in and immediately it's just like
you're transported to like a theme park
you know yeah thought has gone into like
the aesthetic the vibe the design and
then you go to like an anime bar in the
uk and it's a pub with the [ __ ] marker
in the corner that's that's that's
basically like that's what i remember
like that's the absolute state of themed
bars in the uk
i'm saying all this [ __ ] about meltdown
i still had a good night it was a fun
time but it wasn't exactly it wasn't
exactly a gaming bar what's this that's
that's the thing about uk boss you have
fun there you have fun you have fun you
have fun it's just not what you're
expecting
but also has video games right yeah you
told me about it but we decided not to
go to it for whatever reason it's kind
of far out the way yeah we went there i
went there the other when i went back to
the uk recently just for a drink and it
was rock band night right and uh it was
rough really because people are singing
anymore anyone else so it's basically
karaoke bar kind of karaoke but i don't
know why rock band makes people worse
singers but it was like i remember it
was rough i remember i was there i was
like oh i you know i don't want to judge
singers because i'm [ __ ] myself but i
was like this is this is hard to drink
with this is this is like wedding single
vibes yeah yeah yeah even worse than
that
yeah i i think just the problem with
having themed bars in the uk especially
is that if you are going for like a more
delicate theme that requires more you
know that requires more thought and more
precision is that you have to make
everything drunk proof and not just
drunk but just like uk people drunk
proof and that's just like that's like a
much higher level chaos like because
this board game had a bouncer
so that should tell you how much like
this state of the uk the absolute state
a board game bar right where you would
think that you know
us as nerds would go right we're like
chill right we need a [ __ ] bouncer
for it hold it right there what's your
top score scrabble all right
you got a mortgage that probably makes
you stop you right there you're broke
monopoly have you finished a monopoly
game all right
so we got someone stabbed over a game
with uno the other night you know like
yeah that's kind of sad you're like yeah
like what's wrong with that so i can't
just [ __ ] not be [ __ ]
i've heard there's a lot of really fun
uh board game bars in tokyo i've never
been to any of them but i've i know of a
couple that i want to go to there's a
few in london actually there's one new
uh gaming bar
well there's one next to the ereza bar
right uh there is a cafe in uh in
akihabara yeah there's a board game bar
there
probably you need one that you'd kind of
if you're if you can't read japanese you
need to be somewhat familiar yeah that's
fine if you know a lot of them or you
have someone who can explain yeah yeah
most of these games i'm like i don't
want to read the manual i'll play it
with someone who knows they can just
explain yeah yeah it's much better yeah
like if if there is anyone living in the
uk that just does legitimately go to a
cool thin bar please i would actually
like to know if
if the uk bar game hasn't has improved
since i've moved out of the uk
because like yeah compared to compared
to into what's available internationally
it is it is weak i will say that it is
weak but i mean i understand it yeah why
hello you lovely listeners and watchers
of the podcast it is i joey your boy and
i'm here to tell you about the lovely
sponsor for today
moksu here makes such a perfect and
memorable gift for anyone in your life
who appreciates japanese snacks and
culture especially during a time when
people aren't able to travel around as
easily as they could and this being the
month of february it is the season of
love and boxer here's got you covered
with all of these sweet snacks to share
with your special and loved ones for
example why not try this hokkaido white
raspberry a beautiful combination of rye
rice and puffed corn coated in that
hokkaido signature white chocolate and
don't worry if you're not too much of a
sweet tooth because you can wash all of
it down with some beautiful organic
horizon but you know what the most
amazing part about this whole thing is
is not just the fact that you can get
these amazing snacks but if you use our
code trash taste 10 you can actually get
10 off your subscription so go and get
yourself or a special loved one a boxu
this february thank you to boxer for
sponsoring the video back to the show i
watched more anime
i did too actually what did you watch i
watched attack on time oh me too me too
what is going on now
joey's watched as joey's only and first
animation
he can't just drop this bombshell on me
guys i i i tweeted it i watch anime i i
tweeted about how uh the first two
episodes were wild and then i
immediately uh silenced yeah you got a
friend you got it yeah i muted it yeah i
didn't see it at all but i guarantee all
the comments were like you don't watch
anime by the time this episode comes out
i think episode six
sounding like that yeah it's like 12
episodes of the season oh really yeah
yeah
i had to almost i had to go back a
couple of episodes just because it
really does just like throw you in well
i mean it is uh just a continuation
right right right just and
i think i've completely forgotten about
that i was like oh it's just the new
season right so i was like i was waiting
for like the recap
and i was like where is it where is it
what's happening because like now anime
has this thing where they call things
seasons but they're really not [ __ ]
seasons like it's it's just parts
it's final season part two yeah right
there part two of season three yeah that
was a part two of season three so season
three part one season three part two and
then final season part one final season
part two because cause like the last
season wasn't really a season cause it
was just a story arc that was cut right
in the middle of the story right so i
wouldn't really call that like a full
season you know so this was just like
the continuation of the attack on time
and i completely forgot about that when
i started the first episode of part two
yeah so we just [ __ ] say that
final season yeah when i started episode
one final season part two final season
the actual finals yeah the actual final
season supposedly but uh yeah it's deja
looks pretty good this season huh
cgi looks pretty good this year
it doesn't look that bad actually the
tides have gotten a lot better yeah cgi
i don't know
i haven't actually watched the new uh
attack on titan season i i don't know if
i'm just being like i'm i'm just used to
it but yeah i think the cgi titans look
a lot better than they did in the
previous season
i didn't really notice that until i saw
on twitter that people were complaining
about i was like oh well well you know
they complain about anything yeah
exactly exactly i feel like detectives
i'm sorry i found the cgi guys i did it
yeah right i saw it if i cross reference
the manga panel that they took this from
like i saw a guy on twitter like
complaining about the cgi and part six
jojo as well like the other day where he
was literally like i i don't know who it
was but i saw an image where it was like
side beside comparison with like arrows
of just like this is part five and this
is how many cgi things are in the
background and this is part six and this
is how many cgi things there are in the
background
i'm just like we are getting to like the
[ __ ] always sunny charlie meme at
this point you know like you know like i
i i can't comment on the attack on titan
final season cgi but it wasn't too bad
why do people part one people just hate
cgi they just like the the 2d art style
i get it you know obviously i would
prefer 2d yeah i don't i would have used
any sleepover cgi being included i'm not
yeah
i don't really care i mean does it does
it affects the story
or the impact of the story
i get more annoyed when they just don't
even animate stuff like i think there
was a fight in the previous part one of
final season that i wish they'd animated
there's a fight in it that i wish that
they'd actually done something with but
they just kind of didn't show anything
okay they kind of like cut to the
aftermath of it yeah that's when i'm
like well that's [ __ ] i'm like show me
something even if it's cgi i'd love to
have something to do with levi yeah yeah
okay okay i know i know the moment yeah
yeah yeah that one that one was kind of
disappointing yeah that was another one
really disappointing show anything
that's where i'm like okay now this is
[ __ ] when they're not even showing the
fight yeah yeah that's what it bothers
me the only thing i would say that i
think has been a step down is that the
story of attack on titan final season
has been amazing but
um compared to like what previous
seasons did that wasn't like that epic
oh my god fight moments yeah um and i
feel like that's the only thing that's
really missing from this final season or
that has been missing because like there
are some amazing action moments in the
previous seasons and this one has just
been amazing for the story yeah the
conflict yeah i you i look forward less
and less for the action scenes and more
so what's gonna happen whereas you know
like
season three part one i had that
glorious uh scene which you've probably
seen all over because the gifts are like
yeah
that's [ __ ] like anything involving levi
is just like that
it was kind of interesting when that
came out you know everyone was like
joking that attack on titan season two
was so boring yeah and then that that
scene came out in part in season three
and everyone was just like a tackle
tight hype again everyone was like that
one scene made everyone hyped for attack
on titan yeah it was so well done it was
insane yeah i mean i mean there were
even like some scenes in season two
though like [ __ ] incredible as well
people just didn't care cause it took
five years right or like four years yeah
it took like yeah five
five six it also
it was also the point it was also the
point where the story started to get
like had like the political side of it
all like in the story in the world
so it was a lot harder for people to get
like hyped over there they weren't going
to be like yo politics hype you know
they weren't gonna but i think that's
just because it was like so different
from season one because season one was
just like it was so fast-paced and so
action-packed that people like it was so
cut and dry and like straight to the
point yeah like this is what's happening
you're gonna get hyped for this fight
this fight this fight yeah yeah yeah and
i i'm glad they slowed it down in season
two and literally like built up the
characters built up this world because
that now i think it's so much better for
it it's like a much
like the pale show for like the action
scenes now has just become like so much
greater yeah even though part the final
season part two right now there isn't
really any like fight scene that's made
me go i mean i've only seen the first
two episodes but like there hasn't been
a fight scene that's made me go like
everything's a fight right now
if anything the one thing that's been
talked about is that [ __ ] face right
oh my god yeah that's been like mean i
don't i don't even know the context of
that yeah i've seen it like on my
timeline yeah this caught me off guard
that caught me off guard as well yeah i
was like whoa
it's like a horror anime now what the
[ __ ] i guess i guess it'll be
interesting to see how our opinions
change when it's over and yeah our final
thoughts on it yeah interesting i would
be interested in following it now for
like i don't know six
do you think do you feel like this is
the anime that has like just defined
this modern generation of anime fans
yeah yeah this is going to be the show
for the next 10 years that when someone
was like i want to watch anime what do i
watch
go back on the greats of the 2000s and
it's like well
obviously
yeah because it is it is like as much
people want to be like no it's [ __ ]
whatever because they want to have like
a counter opinion like no it is it is
like this it's a great show i'm
generation i'm interested to see how the
ending is gonna go down
um because whether it is good or not
because i don't know because i'm not a
margarita whether it's good or not um
the anime community is probably going to
explode one way or the other yeah
right through through discussion i still
don't i don't know how i've like [ __ ]
dodged all these spoilers i don't know
anything
yeah because whenever you even like
utter the word attack on titan ending
all the [ __ ] mongerie just come out
of the shadows like war veterans being
like uh
yo yo you're just
you'll see one of these
it's divisive yeah it's good that means
it's gonna be interesting yeah i'm
excited because if it was if everyone
agreed like it's decent i'd be like [ __ ]
now that i know it's divisive i know
that i'm i'm in for something good yeah
i'm like i'm like
i'm like preparing a nuclear shelter for
a [ __ ] twitter that's when the ending
comes out i know that twitter is going
to be like a [ __ ] landmine oh yeah
definitely
i'm hyped for it i'm hyped any opinion
will be shattered
by the opposite party it's going to be
one of those shows where you you just
need to watch it just so you can have a
take on it you know yeah like your
personality is going to be defined on
whether you on what take you have on the
attackers
we'll be asking you what you felt about
the ending of attack
so my credentials for a boyfriend over
six feet uh i thought the ending of
attack on titan was good
if you don't fit please get out that's
how you know man it'll be interesting
i'm really really hyped and also it's
probably the
longest anime that i've been following
where it's like okay it's finally like
an end is in sight yeah and like an
actual ending not a oh they [ __ ] up
the production oh it's gone now it's
never gonna yeah yeah it's like an
actual wrap-up of a long-running game
yeah it's i can't even remember the last
time i experienced something like this
where i was just watching an anime and
it was like it just ended and it's i had
to wait years for it to end actually i
know it's even getting on but
aside from that i just realized it it's
just all coming it's just all come
recently start
every single phase of attack on titan
hype and controversy and everything yeah
i've been through it all so having it
come to an end is gonna feel so weird
yeah because even like if you're like
all right well one piece it's like yeah
but one piece is around before you were
around right kind of watching well it
started in 96 money right were you
reading one
right like imagine if you're like a 50
year old japanese salary man who's been
reading one piece into your 20s it must
be like really weird to think that one
day it's going to end yeah yeah unless
you've been around for ever and
conscious around every single phase of
it well that's that's what a bunch of 50
year old salary men were like when
naruto ended right yeah true well like
you know like bleach right it's like
it's like oh my god crazy [ __ ] over i
don't know like to me naruto the
narrator only got like soured by the
fact that boruto i think was like
announced right even like before
it ended so i'm just like well it's an
ending i'm i'm emotional but i know it's
not really ending and because there's
more of it yeah because there's already
more of them yeah you know that's true i
wish i could go back and watch death
note like what episode one through like
30 seconds just log on to twitch i know
i hate it
could you imagine if you were around
when death note was uh if it was an
anime only and it was like week by week
holy [ __ ] that would have been crazy i
wish i was there
i mean i was i was there during the
second half of when the manga was
serializing yeah and even that was
[ __ ] crazy yeah and like and even
because like i it obviously started
before i started reading showing a job
right so i had to like do a quick catch
up to like keep up with everyone and
even then that was [ __ ] crazy should
only imagine the levels of hype that it
would reach nowadays something like that
dropped today yeah it was it was weird
because i i was one of the guys who was
watching like death note when it adds
and it was just a different vibe because
rather than people discussing it weekly
you just you just had people be like
watch death note it's amazing so you'd
only get like discussions of the entire
show after it finished as opposed to yo
did you catch the newest episode [ __ ]
yeah
i let it got removed from the alphabet
well that was [ __ ] insane man
it's true though i wish i wish i could
have been around with something like
that i don't even know like it's so i
guess i don't know what the next show is
that's going to be like that one i don't
know maybe mushoka tensei i don't know
maybe i hope so i mean it's it's it's a
hard shoe to fill but just because it's
we you very rarely see anime that
literally appeals to everyone and has
everything that everyone likes yeah
everything i i do hope the next one is
mishka tensei because they literally
created a studio just to make this one
show
but they kind of need to because of how
long the story is it follows like his
entire life how many episodes do you
think you'll probably need like six
seasons
sixties that's yeah because many
compared to like one piece or something
that's true that's true but like in
terms of that many
high quality episodes that's that's like
yeah
and it feels like more like an
autobiography or like a biography of a
fictional character kind of like uh you
guys ever seen like boyhood or that
movie
uh
what's that i just sound so familiar
that's that was a movie that like took
15 years to make
because it was they basically it
basically is the story of this kid and
um and how they did it is that they
filmed every year for 15 years i think
you've seen clips that's pretty cool
yeah
yeah so they
yeah do you remember that i think did he
win an oscar
you'd [ __ ] hope so yeah after 15
years yeah it was talked about was it
boyhood i can't remember if that was
there was a movie like that they did
yeah no you can just go on youtube and
watch those family channels just raise
their kids
[Laughter]
yeah
who needs that now the groundbreaking
thing has now been turned into ad
revenue so now now a compelling piece of
media is just filmed farmed on youtube
yeah why why condense it into a
feature-length film when you can make
multiples so much more ad revenue if
you're doing you know day by day uploads
you know my kids should himself vlog you
know like episode 4
700.
the kid gets called up by the principal
and they film it they're like film
picking the kid up from school after
he's been like kicked out
it's insane no this [ __ ] is insane
family vlog channels are so weird to me
it's the most scariest part of the
internet for me that's what scares me i
i can't imagine
it scares me because i can't imagine i
mean it's the complete opposite of like
a healthy environment to raise children
in right because i know it's awful like
imagine imagine you're a kid and you're
just like grown up just thinking that
everything you're gonna do is gonna be
filmed and you have to like permanently
be on entertaining mode
right we're only years away from like
the first influencer who was raised
in an influencer
like house yeah you know what i mean i
mean they're probably already born yeah
it's in like what i'm saying is like
there's probably there must be one of
those kids on one of those family
channels he's gonna be like the first
big like youtuber or something where his
whole entire life has been documented
willingly awful awful just not black
mirror [ __ ] right there yeah really it's
literally just truman show right it is
true
terrifying terrifying stuff the kid is
raised not not not on his uh what he
should be taught in school but how to
use google analytics and google trends
what a terrifying thought
what terrifying thought
awful it's so scary what did you want to
say ashley what do you want to know
about boywood it won
how long did it like take to make
2002 to
2013.
so so 11 years 11 years so i i know it
got like cancelled it almost got
cancelled because the cast members just
wanted to stop doing it like imagine
being tied to a project for like 11
years and having to do this one thing
every year even though you never know if
the film is gonna be even be finished
and released i mean that's yeah that's
cause like 11 years is literally you
know a kid just starting school to
almost graduating school yeah that's a
long time yeah especially for a kid yeah
that is the entire point of the movie
because you literally get to see this
kid grow up oh my god and a lot of it
like wasn't scripted a lot of it i i
might be talking my ass but like i know
like they had i think i had the rough
plan but because they didn't know what
would happen in life
sometimes they had to change the script
every year depending on depending on
what happened so i mean i highly
recommend you guys watch it it's a
[ __ ] amazing film sounds good um yeah
because like it's it's rare to see a
project that lasts for a long time and
you get to see the end of that project
and i think some some things like attack
on titan is such a rarity that we should
cherish it whenever we do get to see
something like this i i guess i had a
normie anime weekend because i also
watched the new season of demon slow ah
oh yeah how how is that i've never
started it it's so good it's crazy man
so i watched the movie right before i
watched the new season
and the animation in the season was like
way better than the movie really
i'm not kidding really yeah i i was
watching the train arc thinking waiting
for some like insane you know movie
budget animation kicking and i was like
oh it's not really that much different
from the episode i would say the last
fight scene was pretty crazy though it
was pretty the last fight scene was
nothing like that they didn't already do
in the like the tv show i guess yeah the
bar of quality was pretty high i don't
know i don't know who's in charge of the
animation there but holy [ __ ] how did
they even step it up more like there was
a
man discovers you photos yeah
it was just like how do they keep doing
this how do they keep getting away with
it like it's like mapper as well like
every year they just step it up somehow
the new season of demon slayer is really
good and i hate to be that normally guy
who's like yo i just heard this amazing
animation
but like it's it's it's good it's really
good yeah really [ __ ] good i've been
meaning to start it just because i did
actually finally get around to watching
it you know after all those years
and i really enjoyed it yeah so
i want to watch it really
i haven't seen the new season demon
slayer and it's one of those shows where
i'm just like i'll watch it when i feel
like watching anime with no pressure to
like make a [ __ ] video about it like
that you'll not yeah because like to me
like attack on titan and demon slay i'm
like everyone already knows these shows
i don't need to make another video about
them yet come on think about it the
address
the seo one more attack on time one more
time in time come on it wraps up we
gotta do another attack i'll do i'll do
another one when it ends okay you have
to yeah and then that and then there'll
be i think i've made like [ __ ] four
videos i'm talking about attack on titan
is still a masterpiece
i can't form an opinion unless gig also
agrees with it yeah that's right
on his uh on his video about it you know
i if he says it's a masterpiece it's a
masterpiece i need that strong nine to a
light 10 you know
like okay there we go
i mean would you say demon slayer like
would you say it's as good as the first
season or is it like even better
did the last season come out how many
years ago is that now
26 2019.
right before we moved to japan right
was it 2019 i thought it was a before
that because i i feel like i don't know
if i'm just like i'm forgetting but i
feel like it's better than the first
season oh yeah i feel like i've been
enjoying it a lot more mm-hmm
uh and they got like right into it it
was nice no [ __ ] around yeah it's
good yeah well i
i feel like the first season it did take
a lot of time to get going i felt like
it was just like the first half of
the first half of demon slayer season
one
is uh was i mean it was just very
standard shonen stuff you know it was
like it was nice it was like comfort
food you know you knew what you were
getting and it was only until like the
[ __ ] spider arc where i feel like it
actually got yeah it kicked off really
really good i don't know i feel like
this season so far i'm on episode seven
uh yeah really impressed with it so far
i've not a single episode i thought was
boring pacing's really good
animation is just god tier although i
must say like one aspect of demon slayer
that i've just like never really
understood it's like i don't know it's
it's a good show right yeah but do you
think it deserves as much of like an
insane hype in japan as it does i mean
what i mean in japan it's worldwide no
no but like i feel in japan it's on
another it's hard to explain if you
don't live here like how insane the hype
commits like everyone knows kimetsu is
[ __ ] popular everywhere right yeah
everyone's watching the new season
everyone went to go see the new movie
but like yeah in japan it's when i say
some when something is inescapable
that i feel kimetsu in japan perfectly
suits that word because everywhere you
look yeah some product or some store or
something is doing something with
kimitsu yeah even like five-year-olds to
like eighty-year-old dude like my entire
japanese side of the family has like a
favorite like a top three characters
like demon slayer it's like it's so
weird that it's so weird that like i so
like i have like a like a four-year-old
cousin right who obviously loves demon
slayer right because [ __ ] every kid
loves these players so like for for
christmas i was like breathing yeah
so for christmas i was like oh i'm gonna
get him something demon slayer related
right so i asked his mom my cousin just
being like
uh what what is uh what is his favorite
character right and she just lists off
like two or three characters i was like
all right cool easy and then she was
like oh by the way i like this character
uh my your uncle likes this character
your aunt likes this character and i'm
like what
imagine imagine my 60 something year old
uncle being like yeah i [ __ ] love
shinobu dude like she's like my [ __ ]
favorite character i'm like that's so
weird it's so weird how in japan
literally everyone
of every age generation is watching
demon slayer or has watched it it's
intense yeah do you think it's the movie
that's got got it this big because i
didn't realize how big it was
no no i think it was already big i think
how big it already is was the reason why
the movie is like the
[ __ ] like highest grossing anime
because because like it was like that
one year where he beat out one piece by
manga sales but like tenfold or
something it was yeah it was like oh
yeah it was like more than that
before like it was like the years before
that the top selling mango was like one
piece one piece one piece one piece one
piece by like a long shot yeah and then
demon slayer came out and it was just
like yeah let me like ten times like
you're it was still hilarious when you
saw the graph because it was like all
these other shonen jump stuff and then
it's like one piece it's like demon
slayer because within 2019 the the
like weekly rankings for demons like the
other the manga rankings like demon
slave was like everything yeah it was
every week
i was like second and first and then
like it's a fight between us yeah
because i was going to say jiu-jitsu
guys and seems almost equally as
inescapable recently because of the new
movie yeah because the new movie but
like even before that like after we got
released it just it just seemed like it
just had such a big explosion
and i'm not sure like
i haven't been living in japan long
enough to see like how
big or how fast trends come and go but
like it it was way bigger than i thought
it was going to be yeah i mean like you
know in japan trends come and go so
quickly because i feel once something
trends in japan yeah japan just milks
the absolute [ __ ] out of it like you
know
throwback if you can remember ppap for
instance
back in the [ __ ] day right for you
kids that's pen pineapple apple pen
uh when that was [ __ ] big like three
or four years ago how long it was longer
than that i think it was longer than
that right like that was [ __ ]
everywhere yeah in japan
and it's crazy like when you go to the
supermarket they play it yeah right like
it still has staying power but like
i don't know
i don't know what it is about demon
slayer specifically when it comes to
like a a trending anime in japan because
every i feel there's always
that one series that is trending
everywhere in japan right like during
the different periods like it's it's
nothing new to demon slayer i feel in
japan yeah but i was like what is it
about demon slayer specifically
that it's literally appealing to every
single generation i don't know i don't
get it it's a good show you have like
the family-friendly appeal right yeah
like i can't imagine a four-year-old
watching these demons like heads getting
cut off right being like that's not the
same as like beauty and the beast yeah
right it's not like a disney ip or you
know like a pixar ip or anything like
that right where it can appeal to the
family like even comparing it to like
other anime or other shonen it's just
it's it's good it's it's good it's
a good show every time i make this
argument people just think oh you're
just a demon slayer like hater i'm like
i'm not i enjoy the show but i just
don't understand what about this show
specifically yeah that is
literally inescapable i don't even think
it's like my top three shonen oh it's
definitely not in my tongue
the animation is just so good it makes
it so easy to watch right oh this is
just amazing it's just insane but the
thing is it's not only because of the
anime though but because you know like
the manga
as well right so it's something like
fundamental about demon slayer that is
somehow appealing to
everyone and i don't get it and and yet
the runtime of the manga was so short
someone needs to write a [ __ ]
dissertation on this man like
it is genuinely
interesting because i i like as good as
demon slayer is i don't know how unique
it is it's it's it's not right it's not
exceedingly unique in any one aspect at
all and it's not like one piece that's
been around for you know 100 volumes
right like i think demonstration only
has like 23 24 volumes or something
which for a shonen jump manga is really
short yeah are there just this many
mouth breathers in the world
it's like just like just it's only
mouthwash maybe they were just lying
from their basement finally
finally representation all right
the total concentration technique is
breathing through your nose
take that ball gag out
my nose has been blocked for like two
weeks i've just i've been a mouthful
there for two weeks that's why i watched
it
hello gentlemen today's episode is
sponsored by harry's 2022 is the year to
break up with new routines this is the
year where you can gift yourself or any
fellow shavers a nice clean shave with
harry's treat yourself or anyone else
the gift of looking damn sharp this
valentine's day new customers can redeem
a harry's free trial set for just three
dollars by going to harrys.com trash
taste harry's delivers a close
comfortable shave at a fair price just
two dollars per blade damn that is cheap
not only that but harry's blades are
designed to stay sharp for longer in a
recent study guys who shave four times a
week said that eighth shave was just as
smooth as their first new harry's
customers can redeem a starter set you
get a five blade razor a weighted handle
foaming shave gel with aloe and a travel
cover to protect all your blades when
you're on the go that's a 13 valley for
just three dollars guys it's literally
free money there's truly never been a
better time to try harry's go to
harry's.com trash taste to try harry's
today thank you to harry for sponsoring
this episode back to the video what is
even like the top character in demon
slayer in terms of like popularity in
terms of popularity yeah it's got to be
tangier right is it tanja it's it's no
it's not
no it's no it's not okay there's
actually i can see there is a lot of
zenith why it's like we it depends
because
i think the the top five definitely is
like tanjiro nezugo uh zanetsu you know
scare and shinobu as like the top five
but like hardcore fans and there's a lot
of hardcore fans of japan all love all
of the hushers yeah the hashtags are
pretty cool yeah
that's you know like i don't know if
that's like their way of being like yeah
i'm a true fan yeah because like with
some shows you immediately you
immediately know what the most popular
character is going to be like yeah
it's easily going to be gojo yeah
everyone's like every that's that's that
character was built to be the most
popular yeah yeah exactly right
but like
in in deemed slay you just don't know
who is going to like i can't think of he
was going to be and if it's zenitsu then
i've lost faith in yanzee
i'm glad i'm not the only one who can't
[ __ ] stand say anything so much
cooler though yeah right i need to i
[ __ ] hate it
i don't i don't understand zany two fans
i don't i don't know it's i mean it's
like i said it's it's it's a good show
this is relatable
[ __ ]
they wish they had some power that could
make them useful
i know why the cast is popular because
you can call every character cinnamon
bun that's uh
why why can't you do that
[Laughter]
i don't know okay i'm trying i'm trying
to like understand this myself i don't
know it's such an interesting like like
social study just because like you know
because we've seen anime [ __ ] your your
entp type whatever the [ __ ] it is tell
me your favorite your favorite hashera
that's how i know that's how i know if
you're a real deal [ __ ] a star sign yeah
yeah you're zodiac cringe bro tell me
your favorite hashtag and why
update.match.com yeah for that moment
because before demon slayer what would
you say was like the biggest like kind
of cultural trend in terms of anime has
has there been like an anime i'm sure
there must be have been like other
animes that have happened
yeah or in terms of like call the
japanese public as much as demon slayer
is doing well slam dunk back in the day
was definitely like around there mainly
right yeah yeah it was like like slam
dunk was so big it became a cultural
phenomenon are you actually in japan or
like the world i'm asking in japan i
don't think in the world there has been
one yet no not really no you're not yet
patreon was for a little bit while it
was out i don't know
i look at one punch man and i'm just
like it was a big deal when it came out
it was a big deal but i i see attack on
titan season four being a bigger deal
let's just have more time to brew yeah
this had more time to like like relish
but but even then comparing like attack
on titan season four to some like other
mainstream stuff it's not there yet it
had hype but it didn't really create
like a cultural like shift yeah or
anything whereas like sometimes you see
in japan they there is a show
that comes along that does create a
cultural shift like slam dunk
uh back in the day um i
like we thought the my hero hype train
was big and then demon slayer came out
and even though i think they're like in
terms of show quality they're around
about the same you know
when we're all getting into this corner
we are not getting into this conner i'm
just saying wait wait which which side
are you on i think the slayer is much
better than mine okay i agree with that
how are you comparing them [ __ ] off
okay in the grand scheme of things i
think that they're of like comparable
level of quality in terms of like if if
someone wants to say looking forward to
the song
what i'm trying to say if if someone
wants to say that they prefer my hero
academia over demon slayer i'm not going
to lose my [ __ ] unlike a lot of people
in the community right
my hair
look everyone's telling me that my
hero's gonna come back and see season
six with the my villains academia arc
which i've heard it's amazing it might
be amazing it's shonen like black clover
fans have been saying for years it's
just because and
it's literally it hasn't escaped out of
the monument because like we all know
this i don't know what happened my hair
around season three it just became like
a snore fest i didn't even get to that
point i i can't believe i did i watched
like season three and i was like bored
out my mind watching it i was like this
is so boring just do something
have something happen
be heroes
leave school or something for [ __ ]
sage
that's why hunter hunter was good
because they [ __ ] moved they actually
did something they like got on with the
[ __ ] story until they did it until he
stopped writing it that's why the story
stopped not because he just kept going
in like it was like in purgatory at this
[ __ ] school yeah as an anime only uh
as an anime only what i think what drew
me to by the way yeah as what drew me
out of like what made me lose a lot of
hybrid between
uh in my hero was
you know the first few arcs would
concentrate on the school kids doing
their thing i'm like cool you're getting
to see progression and then they started
introducing the wider world of the
heroes and like these bigger the these
like vast plots that like pertain to the
entire world and you're like cool this
is amazing this is interesting
let's go back to high school afterwards
i'm just like what how can you do this
to me like
let's go let's go to a concert arc that
i don't give a [ __ ] about where you just
introduced like the entire villains
world and i'm just like
and yeah
it feels it feels torn because you're
like just leave the safety net you know
just leave it like you're you clearly
have built this world that's interesting
i think everyone likes the world just
just just let them get out of school
come on come on actually expandable get
on get on with it actually do it but i
get it it's it's safe you can milk it
you can get 10 more years out of it stay
in the [ __ ] school never leave this
thing isn't it isn't the manga ending
soon yeah the manga is ending soon this
year right
did they eventually get out of school is
that to read the manga [ __ ]
well i'm never gonna finish it because
i'm i've lost all interest in the anime
because i was like i i can't wait for
these clips to get like [ __ ] clipped
and put on twitter out of context
i can't i can't wait for shown and
twitter to get on our asses
[ __ ] they're my hero fans what are they
gonna do ask their mum for more fortnite
or roblox like [ __ ] off
what
mama
cancel my trash taste merch
come on it fell off it fell off man it
did it did l ratio no one talks about it
no one talks about that i think that's
the biggest thing is that i don't even
think it's bad i just think it just it
got boring it just got boring but yeah i
i i didn't hate it but like no one talks
about it now i feel like there's no
point watching it because who am i going
to talk to her about no one watches it
yeah i mean and you know maybe the hype
might get reinvigorated in the new
season you know maybe maybe margaritas
are right maybe if it is that good of a
season where everyone gets back on the
hype train fine i'll be a normie i'll
jump back on the hype train i'll get
back into it but like i need a promise
that something's gonna fall yeah but
like
it's been like a season and a half of
just boring stuff and it's been like two
movies of just boring stuff
i watched the movie in the cinema as
well and it was just like i heard it's
just a milk fest yeah oh i was just
nothing happened it was just like i felt
like i went in the loop well that's what
i hate about shonen movies in particular
right because like i like demon slayer
is like an exception because that
actually adapted the manga right but to
me shown in movies just feel like very
high budget filler episodes where you
watch the movie
pretty animation
every one-piece movie yes i mean
everyone no this is true that's why i
don't watch anime movies yeah because
they're just big fillers that make money
that's true but i'm glad to see i felt i
feel like demon slayer finally figured
out how to make a [ __ ] ton of money
whilst also not pissing off tv watches
just release the movie make your billion
dollars and then should be like hey guys
before the new season starts here it all
is in 20 chunks and 20 minute chunks
that you can just watch well i thought
that's great the thing the thing about
the movie i remember watching it i
remember thinking this just feels like a
tv show season yeah it just it literally
had points where i could feel where it
would cut off for an episode and and
then it continued right the money of the
movie but then keep the tv style i mean
so many more seriously gonna start doing
it because of how yeah i mean i i guaran
[ __ ] tia taclentine's gonna do it
i have a feeling i have this like my way
i am what do you think i have this gut
fight i don't think they will
think about the ending of attack when
titan is going to be a movie bold
prediction i think it's going to be a
movie
because because there's no way it would
be leaked because there's no way there
is no [ __ ] way right
like people in the industry saw how good
demon slayer did financially for the
industry and go we can do that again
i think your tinfoil hat on there jerry
attacking titan final final movie final
part one yeah i guarantee three i am go
i am going to bold prediction i don't
care if this ends up being on like
poorly aged things full prediction i
think it's gonna be a movie
oh okay so
it kind of follows the same formula
that's that's all that's all i care
about i just don't want to like when i
watch anime movies i just want to know
that i'm not watching a filler it's
canon right yeah
yeah like don't get me
like don't get me wrong
i've i've seen like almost all the
one-piece movies and they're fun but i'm
not [ __ ] on the edge of my seat
waiting for the next one yeah like you
know what you're going into with a show
in an anime movie yeah you know what's
gonna happen yeah it's gonna be the the
very bog standard three act structure
where where you know exactly what's
gonna happen and how it's gonna happen
maybe there'll be a slight twist but you
know at the end of the day it all gets
resolved because the plot needs to be
resolved to move on it can't be exciting
it's just introduction conflict
resolution and then we end up in the
exactly the same place that we started
because all the time that's what sucks
and that's why i have no interest in
like yeah thus they continued on their
quest that's how it is do you think do
you think that uh chainsaw man getting
released this year is going to reach the
same heights as well
and i would like
i wanted to i want to get that as a fan
of the manga i want this to be talked
about more yeah i have a feeling it
definitely has that potential now um i i
it's been a long time since i've seen
people hype up this one ip this much
yeah like i remember watching the
trailer and the trailer just like it
felt like the trailer just broke the
[ __ ] anime twitter for the day like
you got like a million views in a day on
twitter or something like less than a
day yeah yeah exactly which only got
like a million likes like the actual
tweet that's crazy which is [ __ ] nuts
for an anime trailer it did not fall off
did not get rationed no it did not it
showed every other anime show
i just hope like the hype doesn't
collapse in on itself and everyone
starts watching it and people are just
like oh this wasn't as good as yeah
that's what i'm really scared of i
really hope maple like actually pulls
through with house i don't see why we
have any reason to doubt man i don't i
don't know
but
just like collecting the infinity stones
yeah they're like massive
attack on titan jiu-jitsu [ __ ] yeah
uh [ __ ] chainsaw man
i'm praying i'm praying yeah that was uh
that was the anime talk of trash oh
[Music]
from what i can see i mean
the only memorable things that people
are going to remember the season for
probably those shows yeah um and my
dress-up darling and that's pretty much
going to be it i think that's really
good
that's a good show
um i mean i've only seen like two
episodes it's it's a good show this is
what happens when those kind of rom-coms
or uh no slice of life but kind of
case yeah i don't know how to describe
it that kind of genre of
thing comes out it always comes out
everyone's like 10 out of 10 10 out of
10.
everyone everyone hypes it the [ __ ] up
yeah they're like this is the best
and then like no one talks about it like
right after it's gone it's like it's
forgotten but like to this day there's
still like naruto naruto naruto right
like you know it never it's never gone
like i don't know why can you really
follow me for not watching anime
i don't know i i guess that's because
maybe the characters you can't speculate
as much about or whatever but yeah like
naruto is like was a long-running series
that worked a lot of people great
yeah
[Laughter]
i can't wait for season two of rent a
girlfriend um see i want these videos
where it's like uh you know how like in
those narrow to youtube videos like what
if thingy went against thingy and then
they speculate and it's like what if the
main protagonist and rent a girlfriend
went on tinder let's speculate how well
he would do personally i think he would
get a success rate of 95 percent he'd be
slaying you know but that's just the
theorem
that's just what i'm saying let me know
down below
i don't know
how did he make that speculation yeah
honestly i mean i i believe when
rent-a-girlfriend season two comes out
that's going to be worth watching
because that arc is legitimately going
to be good is it is it going to cover
that chapter though no i should have
brought brenda girlfriend i should have
you know you're going to bring it up so
many times he's the most excited he's
been this entire episode
rent a girlfriend now without just
laughing
there's some real clown [ __ ] yeah if you
know you know i like it's like it's i
feel sorry for anime early watchers
because they're gonna watch season two
and they're gonna think it's really good
because it it was a really good uh it
was a really good arc and they're not
gonna know what's going what they will
never know what hit them well they'll
never know what what's waiting for them
on the other side
um but yeah i mean i've just been done
talking about animation yeah stop
talking about anime now wait wait
everyone leaves we're this this is it
this this is yours you finally played uh
13 sentinels after god's recommendation
last week yep i beat it in three days
yeah so uh obviously you guys watched
last week where i recommended 13
sentinels these guys so i thought you
know i i didn't know if they would take
my recommendation she was in the well of
recommendations yeah yeah i was just i
was just like you know i'm just going to
continue playing it i've like i'm like
playing it at a comfortable pace
and then three days after recording joey
texts me and goes i finished 30 seconds
what the [ __ ] joey i literally went home
that recording night downloaded it
started playing i play i was like i'll
give it a couple of hours right just
like like as god said i'll give it a
couple of hours just to warm up see if i
even get into the groove
i got into the groove all right
because the three days after that it was
just me waking up having like six
coffees just so i could [ __ ] stay
focused in this game playing it for like
10 to 12 hours straight going to bed
yeah
it is like
now now that i have someone to talk to
it about uh i could without spoiling but
we can't talk about it but we can't talk
about it because like i get like now
someone finally understands that i
actually think 13 senators 13 sentinels
might be
the most insane plot i've ever seen in a
video game i haven't even finished it
yet yeah it is it is by far one of the
craziest like video game stories or just
stories in general i've like sat through
yeah it's like so god last week made the
comparison of it's like boccarano mixed
with steins gate yeah right as someone
who's finished the game i can say he's
right on that but only on like a surface
level because it's like it is like it
has elements of bulk runner like with
the robots and it has elements of steins
game which is the the time traveling
aspect but then you combine that with
like ghosts in the shell and the matrix
oh god and that's and and just imagine
all four of those
mashed into one story how is that
cohesive
somehow i don't know how they did it i
don't know how it's but it but it is out
of ten out of ten like strong nine wow i
haven't finished it yet but like playing
through it now you get to about the
third of the waypoint right and you
think like because i'm going to say
there are there are twists
obviously
there are twists in this story and i
remember i remember getting about the
third of the way through i'm just like i
know the twist
i know that's gonna happen and then sure
enough what i predicted happened and
then that was just like the twist that
leaded into another twist that lead into
that lead it into a [ __ ] bigger twist
like there were moments as i was playing
especially the second half where you
think like you're like all right
this same story has been told from 13
different perspectives right so you're
like so you follow everything you're
like okay i think i know what's going on
and i think i can predict what's about
to happen but there were moments where a
character would say one line and i
literally have to put my controller down
just to be like
i don't believe you just said that
because now what i thought i knew about
this game is completely out of the
window yeah
but it's still but it's not like but it
doesn't come out of left field either i
genuinely want to know
what the writing process is what the
writing process is it's so it's so
insane how many times
you get [ __ ] actual physical whiplash
for like new new plot elements that get
added that seems that make that it's
like bat [ __ ] crazy if you explain it
out of context but like in context it
makes the most perfect sense it makes
perfect sense it makes like the [ __ ]
fate law look like disney you know
kingdom kingdom i think i said to god i
text the god saying it makes the kingdom
hearts law look like sesame street
like kingdom heart fans are going
finally a coherent story i can follow
along with you know like it's it's
it's like i i can't i can't put into
words how actual insane the story is but
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] incredible i
don't know how it works but it just does
like and we were saying like
i i don't know how more people haven't
heard about this even in like the jrpg
community because even like the jrpg
community is a very tight-knit community
whereas if something's good you normally
hear about it from about from like five
different people in the jrpg community i
think the problem is that
because when i tweeted out about it i
thought i was gonna maybe get like three
people being like
you know about it right because again
you don't hear about it but like i think
it just like opened the hatch and like
all the 13 sentinels fans came out be
like yo let's go
because i got so much [ __ ] support
for being like oh he's finally [ __ ]
played the game we've all been trying to
get him to play kind of deal and it's
like i looked because i was curious i
looked into it being like
why have i not heard of this game until
khan told me about yeah and it's because
atlas put literally zero money into the
market
so it they kind of just released it and
was like if you find it here's a gem
yeah but if you don't find it then
you'll never know it existed and i don't
do any marketing
it's because it's because it's literally
impossible to explain the story without
spoiling it yeah actually scratch that
it's literally impossible to explain the
story period
[Laughter]
even if i did spoil it i can't explain
it i was like considering doing a twitch
stream for for this playthrough because
i was like i was like more people need
to like experience the story yeah but
then i was like thinking about what
would the experience be like for a
viewer and like if you switch off for
like five minutes you go you go make a
cup of tea or something you're
completely [ __ ] lost again yeah
because you've missed a piece of
information that's important to someone
else's plot somewhere how long is the
game total so around 30 hours i i think
i beat it in like 32 33 hours i'd say
that's which is short for jr i was going
to say that's probably
not a bad length yeah for
to stream a game i'd say any game that
takes like over like if you're doing a
full-time shift right let's say eight
hours if it takes more than a week it's
probably too long for twitch i mean i i
tried to stream yakuza seven and that's
a really really long game and yeah a lot
of people fell off like maybe like off
like stream six stream seven yeah yeah
people do like those types of games to
watch especially people who have played
it yeah they [ __ ] love those streams
because they're like i want to see
someone else like experience
bits that i thought was insane yeah so
that that's cool but also i don't know
it's easier it's normally easier to
stream those kind of games as well
because you're like you're so invested
that like it doesn't feel like you're
live almost yeah i'm just so into this i
think as well the the problem i because
i thought about it too i was like maybe
i should stream it i don't know but i
thought about it and like i'm glad i
didn't because the reason why i played
it back to back three days in a row is
because i thought to myself if i don't
play this game for more than a day i'm
going to forget everything
like have you forgot everything now uh
yeah
but like i remember how it ends but like
it's the build up to how you're getting
to that end which is what makes it so
interesting it's like it's like you have
the beginning and the end and the
beginning is just like this and then
somewhere it goes
yeah yeah
and then you're just like i i i we're
here
somehow yeah i don't know how we got
here but we got here we got here and it
was it's a bad [ __ ] say insane journey
but it's like one of the most it is it
is literally vsauce intro of the game
it's just like you it's like in this
game you follow as this protagonist
or do you
i am tempted to play because you guys
have hyped up so much i'm like i would
have to stream it i couldn't justify
playing a game that much and not yeah
not monetizing it
for me that's god forbid i don't know i
want to okay the thing is i want to see
you try and do it
just to see just to see if no no just to
see if your audience can even keep up i
don't i don't even know if i could keep
up bro is there a skip option for the
cutscenes uh it's all cut scenes
that's going to be hard to know i mean
you you're basically 100 do they give
you options to skip no okay let's get
that if they don't oh there is a there
is a fast forward option for dialogue
you've already experienced but like
because you experienced the same
small like i i say this with like zero
irony you need the dialogue you need the
doctor you know i know you do that's the
thing is it's hard because i'm like just
get buttons there
let's just say it's not a game i can see
you playing yeah yeah that's why i think
it would be funny to play it as well
because i'm just like sure
well you spent three days playing that i
spent three days like four days playing
four days playing jump king yeah how was
how was that experience hell yeah
it looked like it well i was enjoying
myself in my own space you were being
ridiculed by tens of thousands of people
i know yeah
yeah it was tough it's tough it's really
like soul destroying yeah i don't know
it's a really good game though i want to
play it it's i don't know how to
describe it it's like when when kelly
was on and talking to us about it i
don't think you can appreciate this game
and how difficult it is until you'd play
it yeah i i certainly didn't because
looking at it it looks so simple yeah it
looks
how hard can it be to like judge the
jump but then you're like oh okay well
the only
instinct that gives you like
you cannot see any indication of how
long this jump is going to be other than
your muscle memory yeah how long you
hold the spacebar or controller and how
long are you going to jump and it is
soul crushing because there are some
jumps where it's like it is like a pixel
perfect yeah there's like a one one
tenth of a millisecond window where you
have to get it right
and if you [ __ ] it up you have to go
back and do 50 plus perfect jumps to get
to the opportunity to [ __ ] that one up
again you're right which you'll probably
[ __ ] up again so it's really
soul-destroying and uh yeah it at the
first game i beat it um i did it in one
eight hour stream
which was long but it was fun because
you know i left uh text-to-speech things
on yes people were just insulting me
they were like connor you can't stream
uh you can't you can't keep streaming
this you'll get a dmc for streaming
white men can't jump
and stuff like that and they were like
they were like connor just turn your
monitor upside down you'll be making
good progress
like that just insulting me and it was
really fun i think it made for a really
good stream yeah and then i decided um
because cali said that i sh that she's
thinking i could do the the dlc yeah and
i regret doing the dlc the dlc was so
yeah i i remember you finishing the
original jump king in like one one day
and everyone's like celebrating i was
like good for you because i remember
tuning in in the morning and tuning in
the night and i'm just like connor's
still [ __ ] honest
and he was like finally you've done it
and then when i when i saw cali told you
to do the dlc as well i was like oh so
it's just a little extra that will take
like half extra bonuses an extra bonus
stage that would take half the time and
i remember tuning in one day you were
doing it tuning in the next day you were
still doing it
i was like damn this guy really likes
this game it's cruel man the dlc is so
much harder than their base game so i
think i don't know how many people have
beaten the base game but i know that
only two percent of people who have it
on steam beat the second dlc yeah and
there's a third dlc which is even harder
which i'm too afraid to attempt didn't
ludwig be like all three of them in like
an hour or something yeah logic's insane
yeah i think ludwig's first run of it
though did take 40 hours of the last dlc
[ __ ] hell so just like man's just
built different man
he's crazy though he is insane and like
you can't appreciate these games and how
good ludwig is at them until you do them
yourself and you're like this is
insanity yeah like this is insane like
the sheer amount of muscle memory
required for this game is just absurd
it's just like like a from software game
right like it's like
muscle memory if you're dying dark souls
you go back to the spawn point right
which can be far but in this game it's
like you can lose like two hours of
progress like no checkpoints anywhere
right no so and the the base game
there's points where you can get to
where you're kind of safe you can't fall
too far but the second dlc does points
where like you can fall massively right
yeah and there's never any safe points
and yeah in the third one again there's
another even
harsher jump and it's just brutal i
recommend trying it i don't know why
it's kind of i want to try it yeah i
want to try it as well although
you know there's rage games there's like
not not like getting over it but like
you know there's like cat mario games
back in the day oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah where they were just like
troll it was like it was just [ __ ]
with you this game was
uh
it feels like you never blame the game
when you fail like it's like it's always
you like you're the one who didn't do it
right yeah you never feel like you were
unfairly played there are some sneaky
things they do here yeah but
it's a very rewarding experience however
i do not want to do it again for a long
time
i had horrible anxiety on the last day
because i was getting to the end yeah i
just wanted it to be [ __ ] over with
yeah so i was so close and if i fell i
would go all the way back down yeah it's
just horrible i think my heart rate was
like resting at like 110 or something
because it was just it's nerve-wracking
because you know if you [ __ ] up this one
jump you've got to redo it for three
hours yeah so there's one point during
the dlc on the second day where about
halfway through the stream i'd gotten to
the final part right and i was like oh
my god somehow like i was stuck on this
one stage for hours and then i just
started going through all the stages
perfectly and i was on the very last
stage and i was like oh my god i'm gonna
do it like my heart is like 120 i'm like
[ __ ] holding the space bar and then i
do one big [ __ ] up and i lose like uh
half the progress i'd made and i
couldn't and the rest of the stream i
couldn't get back to where i was right
and i'm just so miserable i went to bed
just so sad i was like this is horrible
i just couldn't do it i couldn't do it
i'm a fake gamer i couldn't do why would
you do that to yourself
because that that conversation you want
the content yeah fantastic twitch
content people love watching a man go
insane and be miserable of course
you know i don't know why anyone would
ever play those games
just for fun
yeah i was gonna ask would you ever
consider playing a game like this if you
didn't stream it
no you couldn't why would you do because
there's absolutely no reason to do it
right if i do it on twitch it's like
okay well it's great content people it's
really easy to understand you know you
play 13 sentinels it's like hey so
here's the 15 characters you need to
know all the in-depth law about by the
way just 10 seconds of dialogue that
changes everything yeah jumping it's
like my mom can understand it yeah if
you fall that's bad
who jumps you literally go up and if you
fall you can sometimes fall really fast
yeah and that's bad you know it's super
easy to get people invested in yeah and
uh yeah it's just fun watching someone
go insane i think i don't know i would
never do it off-stream yeah of course
ever why would you i don't understand
why people have done it i did what what
compels you to keep going i what
compelled me to say satisfaction yeah
right what compelled me to keep going is
that i don't want people call me a
little [ __ ] for quitting right so i was
like i got a cute guy
everyone's gonna call me a little [ __ ]
basically and i also i'm very stubborn
so
oh yeah yeah oh kelly's still going
kelly is still going right now is that
the third dlc uh yeah yeah but i mean by
the time this has gone out i'm sure
callie's beating it right i'm sure let's
let's hope so
hopefully i'm hoping he's insane cali
also is like insane in it cali beat the
base game in like an eight minute speed
run very
really good stuff really insane [ __ ] you
now again i'm i'm much more appreciation
for anyone who's beat that game now
would you ever consider speed running
yeah i was about to ask would you ever
watch
the base game this game's like easy mode
now like that's there's only a few jumps
that scare me in the bass one right the
rest of it's like super easy because
there's like there's margin of error
because like if the platform's wider you
can obviously yeah yeah but sometimes
they do like just like a little pole
yeah and you have literally like you
have to get the arc perfect right and
sometimes there's ice on this the
platform so you can fall off or they're
rounded so it just sounds like those
like really punishing like nes and like
super nintendo games right yeah i feel
that's like kind of becoming a trend
again especially in the game yeah world
i feel i'd feel like but sometimes those
nes games were just [ __ ] oh yeah
they were like unfair i feel like this
was
an experience that is very challenging
but also very rewarding weirdly yeah
like i've never felt more accomplished
about a video game yeah i i felt that
when i streamed uh hollow knight uh a
while back like that game is like
[ __ ] unforgiving and so yeah and to
this day i haven't beaten it just
because this is one boss where i'm just
like this is [ __ ] right right
those are the types of games when you
beat it you're just like yeah when you
beat it's like [ __ ] yeah let's go yeah
yeah i don't know i feel like i learned
a lot about myself in those 30 hours
i learned an awful lot about me and who
i am by just i mean
you kind of have to right
you play a game like that for that long
which i don't know how the [ __ ] you do
respect to you for being a true gamer
yeah i can't even play not a gamer i
can't even play a game that has like
more than five inputs for like more than
three hours you know [ __ ] just just
pressing one spacebar and just jumping
for like 10 hours i can't [ __ ] i was
sweating playing 13 signals and you
literally just press circle
i'm sure i'm getting i'm pretty sure i'm
getting repetitive strain injury
repetitive
rsi rsi rsi i was pretty sure i was
getting that after a while because i was
like
it's my number yeah yeah it's good
though i really do recommend trying it
yeah i definitely want to stream it just
uh you should i really want to we should
race through it yeah you guys should do
a stream we should race it i'll
commentate this yeah it's stressful no
no because if you no one expects you i
don't want to do it on my own
the first time you want to you want me
to suffer with you joey i don't want to
be alone by myself with chad just
[ __ ] doing this all right
i want someone to be there would love
that people would love that you've got
to do this now this is a brilliant idea
yeah come on let's do it if you're going
yes god do it i'm driving you easy just
press the space oh oh [ __ ] it i just
love the way joe was like yeah i'll do
it right yeah
you're with me right now
don't say you're gonna beat it just say
like you're just gonna play it and see
what happens and because if i play i'm
gonna beat it
that's the thing right if i start
if if i start
i'm saying it if i start then that's my
commitment well now i can't [ __ ] do
with you because i have to i know you
don't have to you don't have to no you
don't you don't you do it you don't have
to you don't have to
it you can do it you know what mama
didn't raise no quitter
mama didn't raise the baby
but
in 4k she raised someone who is so
afraid of failure that if you don't
start someone you don't need to quit
you're going to play it
oh my god
but no like uh yeah i mean it looked
fun i guess
big air quotations and fun like you
completing it looked fun i i didn't i
didn't like see it looks it didn't look
funny it looked satisfying it looks
satisfying it's very satisfying yeah
it's got a good soundtrack too yeah yeah
meanwhile like joey's doing his best to
try and like convince me to not pick up
final fantasy online because uh
shut up
i'm doing this man a favor right now i'm
saving a life
it's like a different game so so like
last last week i off like me and sydney
offhandly mentioned that we maybe were
interested in getting into final fantasy
online and joey like joey perked up like
we just mentioned that we wanted to try
crack or heroin or something it's like
god what did you just say i think i
think i'd be more understanding if you
said you wanted to try heroin you know
i think that's i think doing heroin is
less life-threatening
okay so i've had friends uh
who have started it since day one yeah
right because they're big final fantasy
fans and and myself i was like okay i'll
give it a go yeah but then i remember
but then like
nam flashbacks came back to me of like
times where i used to be like heavily
addicted to mmos right where like i
would literally
what basically think of my three-day
streak with 13 sentinels but over the
course of like three years yeah right
right that was my experience with mmos
right that's why i don't touch him right
and so i i tried it i did the trial for
final fantasy 14 because you could do
like a trial period without actually
purchasing the game okay um and i did
that
really fun
but i was i stopped myself i was like no
i cannot i cannot do it you got some
willpower
i must i unlocked 100 of my brain to be
like joey you are not doing this now not
during the busiest year of your life
you are not you are not going to upload
for a year straight if you start this
right now yeah because i didn't notice
like i didn't know what you were doing
in the like the past
the days that you were playing 13
sentinels yeah but i did notice normally
joey uploads like every other day on his
joey channel yeah suddenly he stopped
uploading dude i didn't
final fantasy 14 i'm i i was like i'm
going to be that way i just know it
because i love final fantasy games i
love mmos and like everyone around me is
playing it as well right so like there's
no there's no better feeling than
playing an mmo with a bunch of mates
yeah that's true obviously
so i was like no i have to stop myself i
i want to be a responsible adult
that actually does what he needs to do
and what's important
you need to be a functioning i need to
be a functioning member of society and
i'm not going to do this and then you
know and [ __ ] all my friends are like
so when are you going to start 14 john
i'm like stop it
it's like a forbidden thing i just don't
go near them yeah i just i know that
they're they're bad for everything in
life exactly
i'm sure i'll have fun were you like
into wow and i was like mmo's back in
the day runescape oh yeah
you know looking back i just think this
is this is insane i would just sit there
clicking on trees for eight hours right
and i'm like what is this yeah i can't
why did i do that
i'm so emotionally invested yeah like
don't get me wrong if i was a teenager
like now and 14 came out i'd be on that
[ __ ]
every day right now but because there's
less i have less responsibilities than i
do now yeah because when we did the
runescape stream uh like i remember i
had a lot of fun and then it dawned on
me that whatever we were doing was like
like twice the speed or like how how
much faster it was like 20 yeah 20 yeah
it was like more than 10 times the speed
it was 20 times speed it was like yeah
it was like 20 10 or 20 xp yeah but it
took us a whole day just to get to one
single boss battle
welcome to runescape how long would that
take if they did we didn't have the xp
multiplayer probably
yeah and like in runescape as well i
think like the last few levels are like
the equivalent to the entire like levels
before yeah so like getting to like 95
and doing like to 99 is that the same as
getting to 95. literally man discovers
how much of a grind runescape people say
one piece fans have commitment like
well the thing was i think the thing
that made runescape so kind of
uh addictive is that you could kind of
just like
kind of hands off it but kind of not
like you could just kind of it's other
monitor [ __ ] you can just click i knew
people who would do that they would have
their normal life but always have
runescape on the other monitor and they
would be like kind of sounds like a
gadget game yeah
i'm just going to say i'm just going to
pretty much pretty much shut you off
they never had sanity or anything yeah
yeah
yeah i think that's what made it so good
never they never tried to stop you right
i feel like people probably put more
money in because it wouldn't stop you
but they never had migration actions
they just had membership yeah yeah oh
they're good old days
so yeah i'm doing everything in my power
right now to stop sydney from getting to
final fantasy 14 because you shouldn't
you shouldn't
i i mean we were just like mildly
curious right we were just like we were
just like maybe we'll maybe we'll look
into this and that's that's how every
drug addiction yeah yeah we were just
like curious just like like mildly
mildly curious um and then we saw that
it had gotten so popular that they
literally removed it from the store
because i remember we we just tried to
like download it so that made you want
to have to play yes yeah
yeah so
classic cinderella
if it's hard to get then he wants it so
like sydney like mentions that she's
going to try and download it and i'm
like i'm like downstairs playing like 13
sentinels or whatever and she's like god
i don't know what's wrong but i don't i
can't download it and i'm just like
sydney come on come on
have you never downloaded a game before
sydney come on
and so i go up and i'm just like cindy
you press the download button and i'm
like trying to scroll down to find out
where the [ __ ] this download button is
i'm like is this the download button no
it just goes into another another pop-up
and i'm like trying to like navigate
this site i like try to go on a steam
page it doesn't give me a download
button so i'm like i'm like so confused
and i realized that they had to like
take it off the store
because their servers literally aren't
big yeah because the servers literally
are too small to handle the player
influx that came in with the new
expansion
this is square enix which is literally
one of the biggest [ __ ] games what's
so good about this expansion that like i
don't know but no it's the story i want
to know
i've heard it's the story and now that
and now and when we couldn't download it
i'm just like okay is there any other
way to download it so i start
researching to see if there's any other
way to download it because now i really
want to [ __ ] play it what are you
like hacking into the screen
yeah
i'm just like there must be a way they
couldn't have just
they couldn't have just taken the file
away surely there's a way to download
the file but like it's uh yeah you
literally can't download it you can't
buy it you can't any like it's it's the
only instance i've seen in the gaming
community where i've tried to give a
money company and they've refused to
accept my money right a money company
yeah that's right sorry i'm money money
i've tried to give a company my money
and uh they refuse to accept here just
let the service be broken and still take
the money
i will fix it yeah well yeah we'll
definitely fix it yeah so i've heard
sales uh coming back on the 25th of
february so stop
no of january sorry so uh that's uh
that's coming up this is the [ __ ]
reason why 16's been delayed for like
two years it's because they're just like
producers yeah yeah i remember when that
game initially released their final
fantasy online that it was
terrible yeah right
it was so bad that they removed it and
they built it they built it up from
scratch yeah again and then the
re-release just [ __ ] exploded yeah
well even when we released that it
wasn't that big was it i don't think it
was big but nowhere near as it is now
it's like i can't escape it yeah it's
been it's been a game where i remember
like one or two people talking about it
it wasn't like a massive explosion but
like slowly over time i just keep
hearing it more and more and more and
it's really it really just [ __ ]
exploded with this new end walker
expansion that's the name right in
walker yeah yeah yeah you know you know
i've been to a lot of like themed cafes
in japan but uh the most i've ever been
to one cafe is the [ __ ] final fantasy
14 cafe just because all my friends like
you want to go to the final fantasy 14
cafe again i'm like i don't even know
this game dude why are you why are you
dragging me into this
shut up
i yeah i don't know i mean i'm sure it's
a good game i'm just never gonna do it
because i don't want to go it's a good
game i just you know have
responsibilities now
i mean i'm sure it's a good game and
i've just been looking for a new game to
get into because it's like minesweeper
minesweeper
you know like there's there's games like
jumping where you know i'll play it for
content but i also want a game where i
can just play you want comfort right
yeah i want to i want to come for games
because once 13 sentinels gets finished
i just i just i just don't know what i'm
going to do with my life yeah we grow
when we leave our comfort zone
we accomplish things
i think they climbed everest in their
comfort zone
you know what i would learn like right
now you know you know we just feel out
we fill that void with more work and i
would like to know what happens if we
just do something fun instead of filling
that void with uh certainly not final
fantasy because i've never [ __ ] seen
it yeah
like three specials this year what's
happening i don't want you to be the
togashi of trash taste all right like i
want you to be present
and here
no hiatuses
he'll break their own like he'll call in
on like zoom and [ __ ]
i'm doing a raid right now but yeah i
can trash taste
if we can talk about final fantasy 14.
oh my god
how many uh how long were you oh yeah
yeah this yeah [ __ ] knobby this
[ __ ] was like you know how he
tried to convince me to play 14. he was
like they have mahjong in final fantasy
14. i'm like what do you think of some
kind of like f like
poker like no one's playing
just because there's mahjong in the game
don't mean doesn't mean i'm gonna be
like yes give it to me
like what do you think i am but like
you're the dog this is like the cheese
and the the pill swallow swallow the
pill joey like it's in a layer of cheese
it's like pavlov's dog from mahjong
it's like
yes i'm playing it
it's like
[ __ ] so rude the only one i'm looking
forward to is the new kirby game
that looked pretty cool yeah that's like
kirby 64 but on switch so it looks
[ __ ] amazing yeah i'm i'm looking
forward to the new horizon zero dawn uh
because the first one is one of my
favorite games of all time and like i
i've i've been waiting biting my time
all this like for like the past two
years to like not buy a ps5 or like to
buy a ps5 when it's fine when the price
has finally gone down yeah and you're
not just buying it from like scrapers or
whatever right and
it's it's like there's now a game i want
to play on ps5 but there's it's still
not [ __ ] available so [ __ ] my life
called them scrapers sorry scouts
scalpers i was like i was i was like is
that the name is that the name scalpers
bottom screwdrivers
they're our bottom screen that's what i
was thinking oh they're like [ __ ]
scratch that bottom screen right yeah
yeah so it looks like i'm going to have
to try and buy a [ __ ] ps5 sometime uh
just to play this game and uh get it
yeah
is there enough games on the ps5 like
that are exclusive at the current moment
no no right because because for me my my
rule of thumb with new consoles is i
need at least like maybe three games
where i'm like i really want to play
this that'll get me to finally buy it
like that's what i did with the switch
that's what i did with the ps4 like if
it's just like one or two games then i'm
like what am i going to do after i
finish that game i'm only getting a ps5
just because that's how much i like all
right or last time i was right i liked
the original series because i'm just
like i am i need to play this game at
launch uh i mean i only bought a ps4 to
play persona five so yeah what are the
really big games that are available on
ps5 i don't know like demon souls demon
souls
spiderman
only nothing games
remake is it is it actually it was if i
was thinking that's why i got the ps4 it
doesn't feel like a true ps5 or like a
next gen and like if it's on like the
gen before yeah yeah kind of like
i mean two second faster load of time
right
the privilege
[Music]
but we'll increase our sales for ps4s
instead
cool thanks
thanks
cheers for that
it's just the global chip shortage right
yeah
can't get any devices yeah it's it's
good gpus can't get
tablets
can't get servers for ffr you couldn't
even get hash browns at mcdonald's for a
while in japan did you hear about what
what what we had a hash brown shortage
in japan for a couple of days look at
the potatoes yeah because of the
potatoes but it was it was so bad to the
point we couldn't even get hash browns
wait wait why was there potato shortage
uh japan doesn't import potatoes
oh yeah okay so they only accept like
their potatoes because they believe that
there so we had a potato shortage we had
a potato shortage was the the french
fries wasn't was it because they
couldn't get the stock like the other
imports maybe i'm pretty sure japan
doesn't import the majority of that
whatever the issue was it was obvious as
a result of the pandemic and then for i
think it was only for like two or three
days
they had this a few years ago with um
potato chips in japan or crisps um they
yeah they didn't have any potatoes
because there was a i think there was a
really bad season and they refused to
import potatoes because they saw them as
lower quality yeah yeah um you know it's
a lot of [ __ ] potential potato let's
be honest yeah i'm not gonna lie like uh
yeah so they didn't have any pizza
potato chips and people were really
angry big salad of course like they
do import yeah fries are processed in
the us and canada before being shipped
oh really they are maybe it's just uh
maybe potato chips then like shipping
the disruptions in on vancouver side so
you can get all right i don't know maybe
it's just for potato chips then japan is
like or like maybe cowbey is like no we
only use japanese we only use japanese
thing not a yeah
yeah i think that makes sense really and
japan japan does they have this massive
culture around their you know vegetables
and ingredients and where it comes from
and it being high quality and it needs
to come from x prefecture otherwise it's
not right and then you taste it and
you're like this is just a very good
version of x thing that i normally eat
anyway for 10 times 10 times i want a
price i want to do a test where we get
the same vegetables that's an after dark
stream yeah from different prefectures
and see if we can figure it out all like
the expensive versus cheap yeah fruits
yeah yeah yeah yeah because because i
will say like you know there are some
fruits where i've had like you you have
like japanese strawberries for example
and i don't think i've had a bat
i don't think i've ever had a bad
japanese strawberry but like it's it's
more of like consistency huh we had bad
strawberries in the uk you know there
are some strawberries where you have and
it's like it's just not that sweet it's
like sometimes it's
a bit sour you know it's still
strawberry but every every every time i
buy a packet of strawberries from japan
it's like three four times the cost but
every [ __ ] strawberry it's like the
sweetest strawberry you would get from a
uk supermarket these are the non-branded
it's also sad that they probably waste a
lot more food as well i probably just
throw away the ones that don't meet the
quality standards right i don't think
it's that i think it's just the quality
of like cultivation is just like
incredibly high yeah okay because like i
remember i think i saw this like
documentary about uh like melons yeah i
saw that one on youtube yeah the melons
one is like the [ __ ] process of that
is like insane like this guy this dude
in like his 50s is like taking better
care of this melon than some parents do
their children like yeah i was taking
better care of the melons than i was
myself yeah right
so it's it's just nuts to think that
like yeah it's like okay yeah now that i
see the process i can't understand why
it's a little more expensive and way
tastier but can it justify me paying
three hundred dollars
i just wish there was a cheaper option
you know yeah
like because i would be fine with it if
there was a natural option that you know
um
rivaled the price of the of the the same
ingredients i would play in like the uk
or i think that's the problem like i
remember i used to eat so much fruit in
australia just because like an apple was
like less than a dollar yeah and it's
just [ __ ] easy to pick up and it was
cheap and it all tasted good but like
in japan like
the cheapest apple you can get is like
300 yen or something yeah and it's just
like i can't justify me spending 30
dollars for an apple sometimes you want
that high quality experience i get that
with every bite that you take but
sometimes you just want to eat a
shitload of one thing and not have to
feel guilty afterwards for spending a
lot of money if you eat steak every day
sometimes you want a hamburger you know
like it's just it's just how it is i
know japan doesn't grow beyond this does
it i don't think it can they can grow
here right
bananas
i think bananas are all imported from
like philippines yeah i love the banana
gacha you know where you're like the
banana gadget you crack open a banana
and you're like i have no idea if this
banana is going to be like [ __ ] or good
right you know what i mean can grow
bananas
oh that makes sense oh okay you just
never know if a banana is going to taste
like the perfect banana right what is
the perfect banana oh no it depends
right some people like are really like
brown and like something oh i hate it
brown no i don't like it you know you
want it to be sometimes you bite into a
banana and it's like fighting back
sometimes it's like kind of tough i
would
yeah i would prefer banana be
too ripe than too brown to me like i i
too ripe it's like rock solid
i prefer when it's like just just like a
tiny bit of firmness just like a tiny
bit of firmness still there that's
that's like my perfect banana it's not
like it's you know it's not completely
green but it's not like it's it's just
just turned completely yellow that's
like to me that's like my perfect banana
yeah i don't like the green ones but
sometimes even you get like a non-green
one and it still is like rock solid or
something yeah it's like yeah i don't
even know what's what's what i'm going
to get with these bananas and frankly i
quite enjoy that i quite enjoy that
maybe i'll get that god tia banana that
is just like really smooth
kind of a little bit sweet you're like
oh this is just the perfect banana why
would you ever play a garcia game when
just you can just but
like you just never know you never know
if you're gonna get a good banana that's
what i love about bananas it's so sad
though because i really miss eating like
a lot of fruits um but just i just again
i can't justify myself it's like banana
is actually one of the cheaper fruits
yeah yeah in japan like yeah because
it's important
you can get in the company yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know maybe like three
bucks for like maybe five or six years i
eat like three bananas a day because
it's just the one fruit i get every
coffee
i actually do you know what i realized
the other day i don't know why i really
really like bananas
i think it's because they're like
pre-portioned okay yeah they're like
they are like we love as humans we love
portion food we love it when something
tells us this is how much you're eating
yeah and the banana is the perfect one i
really really love bananas i like eat
them every day i'm a jojo fan as well
but but i gobble but for some reason i
hate banana flavored stuff like no i
don't i don't know why
there's like i i don't like banana
flavored sweets i just there's just
something depends for me well you know
because the banana flavored stuff is
from uh
a variety of banana that is that we
don't use anymore it's like extinct oh
really yeah because it's it's the is the
the artificial but it has this like
aftertaste that tastes so artificial
that it just really puts me off so it's
like i think it was i don't know if it's
the if the one we use right now is the
cavendish banana or the one before i
know there's a bunch of youtube videos
about this yeah there's the one before
apparently is much sweeter much better
flavor but like a plague wiped out that
that like that uh that type of banana so
they had to grow another one that's more
resistant the problem is that it
apparently doesn't taste as good yeah so
the original banana sweetened flavor
stuff that you taste and stuff
especially that original banana flavor
yeah supposedly right i don't know if
it's true i i don't mind the artificial
i really like the artificial banana
flavor more than the like real banana
flavor so i feel like i've been robbed
you like the artificial banana flavored
more yeah why because i feel like i'm
missing out on the og banana experience
you know i feel like
my ancestors had it good they had the og
banana the sweeter banana the better
banana have you have your sisters or
eaten
stink banana flavor is partner
vanilla flavors actually became more
popular than bananas because nobody ever
eaten my god the mythical banana
yeah because that's that's what that's
what i taste when i taste banana
flavored stuff it doesn't taste like
real banana to me that's because you
your concept of real banana is the only
like one that we grow that is your real
banana flavor is that what a real banana
is that's one variant of banana there's
so many bananas you're always different
you're eating a real banana or actually
like my you are but there are more
flavors than the flavor you know
but no i i know that
resources actually my favorite banana
actually
is
my favorite is actually southeast asian
bananas i don't know
like like
it's like okay i don't know if you ever
love southeast asia i don't know but i'm
saying southeast asian because i've only
had it right thailand huh not european
european bananas are the same [ __ ]
bananas that we import right but
southeast asian bananas are like they're
funny out of context
i can't wait for the banana edit of this
one
jojo fans arguing about dicks
i don't want to go to the comments
section of this clip bananerologist here
no because like in thailand you can get
like these really small bananas that are
like half oh the finger bananas the
finger bananas yeah i like those which
is like what you what is like what they
taste like if you take you you take one
of the four bananas we are used to and
just pack all that flavor in half the
size it's getting the big banana
photoshop
this is a shot of banana like i'm like
[ __ ] addicted to those bananas
because like my my dad comes in with a
pack like they don't even sell them in
like you know packeted um
they don't sell them in like packeted
bunches you just take like you just buy
them by the bunch and like you buy like
a bunch of like 10 or 20 and i swear i
can get through like 10 in a day like i
i like i like eat one and like i'm like
[ __ ] horrible yeah yeah exactly
potassium overflow the [ __ ] ape
the [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] eight brain
just takes over i'm just like [ __ ]
just give me ten right now
do you think that all apples have the
same taste no i don't well then i think
that's the same thing with bananas
except we just don't have to start this
conversation
we don't have the other bananas
right
where have you had the other banana wait
i haven't i want to no one's had it it's
a myth
it exists it's literally a myth it's
like you know we just established all of
the apple flavors are really distinctly
different right yeah yeah it tastes very
very different yes that's what we've
missed out on with bananas
you're speaking about a mythical banana
about this artificial tasting i'm not
way may or may not taste like you've
never tasted it before so how can you
say that this tastes like this mythical
banana you're actually talking about
your ass that's right i want to try this
banana that i know is gonna taste
different what if it doesn't exist what
if it's just it doesn't completely
artificial
in his defense it did exist
it's gone right but we can't have it
anymore god it's gone it did exist but
is that but have they perfectly
replicated that flavor and how it would
be your flavor how do we know because we
want to unite back then you know science
was just a guessing game back then
exactly so how do we know that this
typical banana tastes the same as the
artificial flavor you can just you know
you know speculate based on our app i
can speculate what a [ __ ] dinosaur
tastes like but i know i'm going to
taste the [ __ ] dinosaur i bet it
tastes like a bear like if if someone
came out with like a [ __ ] dinosaur
flavored lollipop or steak or something
i'd be like cool this is completely
[ __ ] because no one's ever tasted
the [ __ ] dinosaur we never got to
taste the dinosaur i wish we could have
tasted what dinner like a t-rex probably
tasted great
we'd be arguing about it later t-rex
would be gamey as [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me
what is that what would be the tastiest
dinosaur like the the tomato let's start
that tommy
probably velociraptor
is like good size no too muscular
they're right
that would be too tough
what's the [ __ ] long neck shits
that's uh
the brachiosaurus brachiosaurus i bet
they tasted delicious you know we missed
out on all these foods and stuff you
know that we could have had trash taste
we've literally run out of food we can
argue about so
let's argue about this let's argue about
food that doesn't exist anymore
i just wake up in a cold sweat and
wonder what bananas we've missed out on
though that does happen
i just don't know if it's ever crossed
your mind what the word artificial means
it means it doesn't exist because
they're speculating the bananas we've
lost
what if the bananas we lost just taste
like absolute garbage i i was i would be
able to sleep probably does because they
are there
extinct because they were little [ __ ]
like gordon ramsay didn't like them they
weren't extinct because the plague wiped
them out gone
it's not one of the players
we died based on the taste
we did you were solid the plague was
like we did you were sold we got rid of
these shitty bananas
we'll give you these other ones you can
imagine what it takes [ __ ] argument
would you ever want to taste a dodo
because man
they went extinct because they got over
hunted so i'm just like damn how good
are
over hunted these [ __ ]
purpose were they whether they have like
a beef that was special or something uh
no because
uh
that tastes good dude do you know why
ashley i can google it for you google it
i'm going to speculate isn't it because
they were just [ __ ] weak animals
[Music]
kind of like i i've heard that dodos
were just like that was just [ __ ]
stupid yeah yeah they're like really
dumb and they were like if there was a
predator that came up to it they
wouldn't even know it was a predator
like that's how dumb they were
supposedly one of the reasons is because
look i've seen ice age
i know exactly what happened natural
habitat was almost completely destroyed
by after people started settling on
mauritius wow
this is why sometimes i watch those
youtube videos where it's like the uh
predator like the animal like there's a
tiger eating a [ __ ] deer yeah yeah
you know and you go in the comments like
oh my god i wish i could have helped the
deer and it's like what stopped nature
like what do you mean like what are you
gonna do
like i hate these comments where they're
like i wish i could have helped that
poor animal like this is literally
nature like just let it do its thing we
would be in this position if it weren't
for where we are right now yeah we're a
plague all right yeah we should probably
know where the problem is we're the
virus like when you're asking a liar not
to like eat it's prey it's like no
that's what a lion does that's like the
whole point that's why that's why
everything exists it's like let it do it
like don't intervene what are you gonna
do just like go to line and be like just
stop
yeah and lie and be like yeah you're
right have you ever tried swimming
veganism that's an option but i think i
think david attenborough spoke about
this one time as well and he was like
someone asked him in an interview there
do you ever feel like sorry for the
animals that like i think this is one
with like the birds were falling down
and yeah and stuff something and he was
like no you know it's just unfortunate
this is life that's that's nature it's
not our place to intervene yeah to get
involved and say
who can do what until obviously we burn
down all the forests
and literally
that that is kind of on us we should
probably intervene as little as possible
yeah yeah
i don't know
i hate those comments
what is it you want to say ashley there
was an animal that was literally eaten
to death though i think it was the giant
tortoise most most worst animals are
eating yeah that's enough
i hate the whole species together okay
that's on us
what animal was that i think it was a
giant tortoise how the [ __ ]
[Music]
i just find it just the image of just a
guy looking at a giant toys being like
delicious i don't know it really was
delicious
i don't know we've eaten a lot weirder
things that is true that's true
if if there's something that's breathing
i'm sure humans have tried to find a way
to eat it
maybe humanity just has trash taste
vsauce music
at the end of the episode
nature is scary or is it
a
uh with nature and scary things uh you
know what's not scary though our patrons
that's true jerry
they survive natural selection yeah
what what is your favorite banana that
you may own the mayor and never have
tell us your favorite
it's the bananas that are widely
available around the world and uh
800. i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna google this
oh there's only ten there's only ten
variants there's just ten but i think
there's more oh
yeah is that a top ten it's a top ten
top ten minutes
but uh hey if you enjoyed the channel
want to support us then make sure to go
to our patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify also tell us
what you think is the tastiest dinosaur
and why
i want a reason how you would you could
age would you uh you know skill it let
us know down below what kind of wood
would you do
dry dry aged vertebrates
this episode of trash taste bye
[Music]
you